Hey guys, and welcome to a brand new tutorial
series. So in this series, I'm going to be
teaching you Java from the beginning. So starting
at the absolute basics, setting up an environment,
how to create variables, methods, like all
that stuff, and then move the old way up into
the advanced stuff. This is a beginner tutorial
series. So I'm going to treat this as if you have
never learned any programming language before.
Okay, so let's go ahead and get started. The first
thing we need to do is download a ID E. And this
is where we're going to be writing our Java code,
okay, so it's called Eclipse, that's what I'm
going to use use whatever you want. But if you're
beginner, I recommend you just follow along with
this, because some of the things I'm going to do
are specific to eclipse. So go to this link,
it's in the description down below, and just
click on download. And then obviously, 32 or 64
bit, I recommend 64 bit as most of you probably
have a 64 bit machine. Once you download this,
if we go Sorry, I've already got an open here,
but if we go to our downloads, we will see
that it should give us something like this,
double click on it, wait for this to boot up
might take a second. Okay, it's going it's going,
let's see. And once we're in here, we're simply
going to select Eclipse IDE. for Java developers,
we don't need to be using any of this other
stuff. Just this one right here. Okay,
so we're going to install this, I already have it
installed. So I'm not going to do that. Nobody's
gonna ask you for a project directory, something
like that. So if it asks you for that, just choose
wherever on your computer, it doesn't really
matter. Okay, so once you've had that installed,
you chose your project directory. Now we're going
to be in Eclipse. Now to start a new project, what
we need to do so it should look something like
this, by the way, you know, click on File, New,
and then Java project. Now here, I'm just gonna
name mine tutorial. And then let's see here, you
can just leave all the rest of this stuff blank.
If you want to change location, go ahead. Alright,
click Finish. And there we are. So once we have
this, it's going to pop up in our left bar,
the package explorer, I'm just gonna shrink
this a little bit. And what we're going to do
is we're going to go down to source or Oh, I
already have a package name tutorial, one second,
I'm going to create a new one really quickly, and
then walk you through this so it's fresh. tutorial
one. Okay, finish. Alright, we got tutorial
one, and we get source. Okay. Now, inside of
the source, what we're going to do is we're going
to right click on this, we're going to click New,
and we're going to click on package. Now, I
recommend you just leave this package name
the same as your project. So I'm going to do that
and click Finish. And then inside of your package
name, I'm going to click New, and plus. Okay, so
once I click class, it's going to pop up here,
it's going to allow you to select the package and
the source folder, just leave those blank. And
the name you can name is whatever you want. In my
case, I'm going to name it main, okay, type names
discouraged. Okay, so let's name it main with
a capital M. All right, just because you have a
like that. And then we're going to do is make sure
you check on this public static void Main, we need
to check mark this because we're gonna need this
function created us so that we can start Alright,
inherited abstract methods, you can uncheck
that. Or actually, we'll check that doesn't
really matter for right now. Okay, so now we're in
and we've got a little bit of code going here. And
I'm going to explain what this is. And then we'll
get into just coding like a really basic thing,
just printing a few things to the screen before
we move into the next tutorial where we talk
about data types. So Java is an object oriented
programming language, meaning that everything
happens inside of something called classes, and
everything is known as like objects. All right.
Now, you're not gonna understand very much of this
right now, if you're beginner, but for some of you
guys that are more advanced, you should come to
understand what this means. So classes are these,
okay? And everything in Java is written in a
class or an interface or something else. But in
our purpose, just think everything is written in
a class right now. Okay. Now inside of this class,
we have a special method is what it's called. And
these methods are what I'm highlighting right now,
inside these curly brackets, public static, void,
main, okay, you don't have to know what all that
what those words mean, just know, this method
is important. And this is where we're gonna be
writing all of our Java code in for right now. So
if you try to write code outside of these little
curly braces, and not inside of this method,
that's what we're calling it right now. Okay,
your code is not going to execute properly unless
you know what you're doing, which in our case,
we don't yet. So all the code we're writing goes
inside of this public static void Main inside of
these curly braces. All right. Now the first
thing I'm going to get us to do is just print
something to the screen. So to print something
in Java, we're going to type system.out.my
computer's lagging one second dot print, ln,
and this simply stands for print line. Okay,
now inside of these brackets here, we can print a
string or whatever we want to print. So a string
in Java is anything encapsulated by two quotation
marks. Whenever we're printing something,
we want to do it in two quotation marks, at least
for right now. And in this case, I would just say
the classic hello world with an exclamation point,
okay. Now, at the end of every line, we write in
Java But with exception of lines that start or end
with curly braces, we need to put a semicolon. And
now you can see once I put the semicolon, that
our system dot out dot print ln gets highlighted,
we can see that it now has syntax highlighting. In
syntax pretty much means any code that we write in
the program. So we have to make sure that whenever
we're done writing a line, we terminate that with
a semicolon. Okay, so now we've officially written
our first program, all it does is print HelloWorld
to the screen, but how can we run this. So first,
we're gonna have to save so I'm going to hit Ctrl
S. And to run this, there's a little green button
up here and says run main dot java. So we're going
to click that. And you can see that down here, a
little thing popped up called console, we printed
to the screen, hello, world. Now that we've
officially created our first Java application,
very simple. And that is how we go about setting
up a new class. And everything that we write
for right now, again, remember is going to happen
inside this method. That's what we're calling it,
I'm gonna explain that later. public static
void Main, we have to put it in here. Now if
you want to print another line, you want to
print something else after we can do that.
I'll show you how that works. So I'm gonna say
System dot out dot print, ln. And I'll say like
hello world, too. And if I save this, and run
again, we get hello world, and hello world too.
So you can see where we are right where we left
off with printing two lines, hello world and hello
world to to the screen. And in this video, I'm
going to be going over variables and data types,
the absolute fundamentals, we have to understand
before we can move on to anything more complex.
So let's talk about what a variable is. Now a
variable just like in mathematics is something
that holds a value. Now in our case, that doesn't
have to be just a number, it could be a string, it
could be a Boolean, and integer, like we're going
to talk about the different values. And those
are what are known as data types, or objects. So
let's start by just creating a variable. To create
a variable, we need to first figure out what
type our variable is going to be. In this case,
I'm going to start with an integer. And then
we're going to go through all the different
types and talk about the differences. So to start,
we're gonna type int, declaring that this variable
that we're about to type out is going to be an
integer, we're then going to give a variable
name. Now the variable name should contain
typically just letters and underscores. Now,
I believe you can use numbers as long as it's at
the end. But in our purpose, we're not going to
do that when we create a variable name, you have
to make sure you do not use any spaces. And you
don't use any special characters as well. So I'll
go through a few examples of valid variable names
and invalid variable names. So a valid variable
name, for example, could be Hello, that's valid,
because we don't have any spaces. We don't have
any special characters, and there's no numbers
and Okay, now, an invalid variable name would
be something like, Hello, name, okay, this whole
thing as our variable name is invalid, because
it contains a space. Now, if I try to put like a,
what do you call it percent sign like this, or
I tried to put like an Asterix, that is not a
valid variable name. So don't use any special
characters. You can end with an underscore, you
could start with an underscore if you want to. But
we're not going to be doing that. In this case.
Typically, when you create a variable, if you want
to make a name, be like to words, the way you do
it is you type like Hello, and then you would do
a capital and then the next word, or you would do
an underscore representing a space. And then next
word, okay, so that's not a valid variable names.
Not super important right now. So I'm going
to create my first variable int hello world,
and that's going to be equal to by just putting
an equal sign, whatever integer I want. So in this
case, we're gonna say five. And then remember,
in Java whenever we end the line, so this is
just saying my integer Hello, world is equal to
five, we need to terminate with a semicolon. So
there we go. And we see we get int, our variable
name is now highlighted in yellow. And there's no
issues. So if I let's just see what it says this
very, is never used. Okay, that's fine. So we've
officially created a variable, the variable name
hello world now points to the integer five. So to
prove this to you, I am simply going to print
out the value of hello world. Like this, okay,
so I'm gonna say system dot out to comment is
System dot out dot print ln. And what we're gonna
do is we're gonna say, okay, so hello, underscore
world. That's our variable name. And that variable
holds five. So when we print this, we should be
printing five. The way this works in the computer,
right? Is it says, Okay, hello, world. Let's
see where hello world is. It's up here. Alright,
hello, world is equal to five. So we print that.
Okay, so there we go. And we get five printed
down here in the bottom of the screen. Now I
want to show you something quickly and this
is just going to go this is a really important
fundamental thing a lot of people don't talk about
in programming tutorials. It's kind of like order
of operations or execution. So I am going to now
put my variable underneath my System dot out dot
Print lm. Okay, so I'm first going to print hello
world. And then I'm going to set hello world equal
to five. Hopefully you guys have realized what
the issue might be here. If not, I'll talk about
it really quickly. And the problem is that I am
trying to print the value of hello world before
I've declared it. Because the in programming
the way things work is unless you otherwise
specify, we're going to be reading from top to
bottom and left to right, just the way you'd read
a book, right? So we first read this line system,
dot out dot print ln a Hello World, and then we
create hello world. So here, we don't know what
hello world is. So if we tried to do this, you
can see it warns me there's an error. Yes. Okay,
you know what, there's an error. Let's proceed
anyways. And you can see that down here,
we get a bunch of red text. And it says, What
do you call it? Hello, world cannot be resolved
to a variable, because we haven't yet declared
that variable. So we have to make sure whenever
we're referencing or using variables that we
first have them declared somewhere above our,
like the line that we're using them in. Okay. So
there we go, we've created a variable hello world,
we print that to the screen. Now, let's create a
few different variables and talk about what these
types are. So in case I didn't really specify
int stands for integer. And that pretty much
stands for any number that does not have a decimal
point. So as soon as I put a decimal like this,
like 5.0, this actually becomes a new data type.
And that data type is called a float. Now float
stands for floating decimal point, which means
any number that has a floating decimal point,
so I'm gonna say float. Let's see, num. Two
is going to be my variable name is equal to,
and in this case, I'm going to say 5.0. What's
the issue here, add casts from double. Okay,
one second where I said double. So sorry, I made
a mistake there. We're just gonna type double here
as the name Okay, not float. Don't worry about
float right now. We'll talk about that later. So
anyways, we have double num two equals 5.0. Now
double is exactly what I was explaining before,
anything that has a floating decimal point. So
even though this is still the exact same values,
this in terms of mathematics, because it has
a floating decimal point in our computer,
is referenced as a double. Okay? Now, there's some
other data types as well, that we're going to talk
about. So we have int, we have double, we also
have something called Boolean. Now, Boolean,
is true or false. And these are gonna be really
important in the next few videos that we talked
about. So Boolean, I'm just gonna say B as my
variable name, is going to be equal to, and in
this case, I'm going to say true. And again, make
sure I'm putting my semicolon. Now, there's only
two values that a that your boolean data type
can have. That is true, or false. Now why these
are important is because based on the value of a
Boolean type, we're going to be doing things later
in our program. Like if B was equal to true, we're
going to print something, otherwise we won't print
something. So that's really important. So another
data type that we have is known as char, no char
is any character. Okay, so this is a little bit
different from string that I talked about in the
last video, but I'm going to talk about string
as well. So I'm gonna say char C, is equal to,
and whenever we create a character, there's two
ways that we can do it, we can do with a Unicode,
which you probably don't know what that is. Or
we could do it with single quotation marks. So by
just simply hitting the single quotation marks, we
can put one letter in the single quotation marks,
and that is a character because that's what char
stands for a character. So like something on
your keyboard, in quotation marks, now character
could be, for example, nine in quotation marks,
so that's still a valid character. Because it's
in quotation marks is different than the number
like nine if you're, if I were to type that
up here, okay? So any letter or character that
goes in quotation marks is a char. Now we have
to be careful, because chars can only be one,
one character, if I tried to, like 03, you can see
that we're getting red text and Java's yelling at
us, and it's saying no, that's not allowed,
because we can only have one thing. Alright,
now I just want to show you I want to go over
again really quickly what the main differences
between this nine and this nine, up here we've
declared, we're going to have an integer named
hello world, and it's set equal to nine. Okay,
that's what it is. This is a character. And
since it's in quotation marks, this is not the
same thing as nine. The way like the data types
really do matter in this sense, okay. So I'm just
gonna change this back to like h something for
now. Okay. Choice equals h. So that is extremely
important. Now string, this is another data type.
It's a different kind of data type, which we'll
talk about in a second. But to make a string,
we do string I believe with a capital We'll see.
And then we give a name. So for our variable,
in this case, I'm just gonna say str is equal to,
and then it this time for string, we use double
quotation marks, okay? And I'm just gonna say
Tim, in here. So chars, single quotation marks,
and strings are double quotation marks, okay? And
strings can contain anything in them. So I could
have like 673 underscore star, that's a completely
valid string, we can put any characters as long as
they're with inside of these quotation marks.
Okay? Same thing with the character, if you put
a nine in a string, this is different than a nine
like this. Okay? So these are our main data types,
there are a few other ones, but I'm not going
to go into them right now. Because they, they're
a bit more complex than than we can handle right
now. So pretty much though, you might notice that
this string is highlighted as a different color
than these and see it is orange doubles, orange,
Booleans, orange chars orange, why is string
blue? Now the reason it's blue? It's because
it's a different type of data type. These four
data types I talked about up top here, are known
as primitive. And, wow, I really just did that
I'm used to typing Python, primitive data types,
okay. And what that stands for, is not changeable.
Okay, and we're going to talk more about primitive
data types and not primitive data types later
on. But just know that these ones that I talked
about here are known as primitive in Java. And
this one is not primitive. Okay. So anyways,
let's just see now, printing out like some
of these data types, like what we get when
we print them to the screen, right. So if I
print, for example, C to the screen, well,
you should guess what we're gonna get, we get H,
because let's see, if we print, str, we get nine,
and so on. Now, last thing I want to show you
with variables is that we can actually make
variables equal to other variables, and we can add
variables, we can subtract variables. And so we're
gonna be doing a lot in the next video, but I want
to just quickly introduce you. So for example,
I want to create a new integer, Okay, I'm gonna
say, new integer, and I'm going to call it,
let's just call it Tim, why not. Now I want
this integer to be equal to nine. Okay,
but I don't want to type nine out, what I'm
going to do is I'm actually going to type Hello,
underscore, underscore world like this. Now what
we've essentially done is we've taken the value
from hello world, and we've assigned it to Tim.
So now if we were to print Tim to the screen,
we get the value nine. Now if I want to print
hello world to the screen, you can see that we are
still getting the value of nine. So now Tim points
to hello world, which points a nine, right, so
Tim is equal to nine and hello world is equal to
nine. And we can do that and we can add variables
together, we can subtract variables, we can do all
kinds of cool things. And that's really the point
of variables, right. So we just have to make sure
when we're doing this, for example, that we don't
do something like this. String temp equals hello
world, you can see here now it says cannot convert
from int to string, because the datatype string
is obviously not the same as nine. So we can't
do that until we learn about something called
typecasting, which will be in a future video.
Now in this video, I'm going to be adding on to
some of the stuff I did with variables in the last
video. And I am going to be talking about basic
operations like plus minus subtraction, division,
exponential, all of that fun stuff. So without
further ado, let's get started. I want I'm first
going to do is just talk about another way that
we can create variables in Java. So earlier,
you saw me do something like this index equals
six, okay, this is fine. This works, we already
know this. But there's another way that we can
actually create this variable. And to do that,
we can actually omit this equal six. So if we
do this, and we just say int x, what happens
now is we've declared that x is a variable,
it exists, but we've not given it a value. So
we've declared it but we have not initialized it.
I'll show you what I mean by this by just doing
System dot out dot print ln, and we're simply
going to print x and just see what we get. Oh,
probably helped I spelt print correctly. Okay.
Wow, I really messed something up, print ln,
okay, run this. And you can see, we are already
warned that there is an error. So we'll proceed
but and it says the local variable x may not have
been initialized. So before we can actually use
the variable x, when we set up like this, we
have to initialize it. Now to do that any line
underneath this declaration, we can just say x is
equal to and then whatever value you want it to
be as long as it's an integer value. So in this
case, I'm going to say x equals six. And now if
we run the program, everything looks fine, and
we get six. Now, obviously, we can do this with
every data type. So if I do like char, and char
x, right, and that's fine, I say char x equals
single quotation marks, f like that. Okay, then we
can print that out, and that will work fine. Now,
what I want to talk about now is operations.
So I am going to create a few variables,
I'm going to say integer x equals five. Don't
forget your semi colon, integer y equals seven
and I'll say int Zed is equal to 50. Okay, I'll
create one more variable. And that's where we're
going to start talking. So what I want to do now
is I want to sum all of these variables. So 56,
seven, and five. But I don't want to write like 56
plus seven plus five, okay? Because Yeah, that's
the value of these variables, this works fine. But
what if I were to change this variable y? Well,
that means I have to go down here and I have to
change this as well to whatever I change y to what
if I want to change x and y? Well, that means I
have to change both of these. So there's a really
cool thing that we can do. And we can just use the
variable names and just add them up. So we can say
x plus y, plus Zed like this, okay. And now our
variable sum stores the value of the sum of these
three variables. And to prove it to you, I will
print it to the screen, and you can see that we
get 68 as our sum. Now, Furthermore, if we wanted
to take the difference of all these and subtract
them, all we have to do is simply replaces with a
minus sign, and we get negative 58. Okay, now to
multiply things, this is another operator, we can
do multiplication like this, replace this one with
multiplication, and we'll multiply all these out
together, you can see we get 1960 as our value to
divide, we can use the forward slash. Now I'm not
going to do that right now, because that is kind
of a different topic. There's a weird thing with
Division I have to talk about. But that's how you
do that. So those are four basic operators. Now,
these work just like they work in math, in terms
of order of operations, right? So we're gonna
start off with exponents, and then go bracket
or brackets, exponents, division, multiplication,
and so on through the process. Okay, I assume you
guys know order of operations. So that means
if I do something like x times y minus said,
What's first going to operate is x multiplied
by y. And then we're going to subtract said from
whatever this value is. Now again, if I switch
this and I go like y, multiplied by said, what's
going to happen first is y multiplied by Zed, and
then the subtraction is going to happen. Now, for
example, if we have the operators that have the
same presidents are the same, I don't know like
order of operation level, I don't know what to
call it. It's just gonna order operate from left
to right, so it's going to do x multiplied by y
multiplied by Zed. So this is a common occurrence
a lot people to understand this. If we do a
division sign, we're first gonna multiply x times
y, and then we're gonna divide by Zed afterwards.
Okay, so that's how that works. Now when we're
whenever we're doing operations like this, we
can also add brackets in. So if I wanted to, for
example, say x multiplied by y, and then divided
by Zed, I could do something like this by throwing
brackets in here. So now it's showing 100% that
we're going to multiply this for we divide. And
same thing, if I did this, now, whatever's
in the brackets is going to happen first. And
then I can divide by said, and obviously we can
embed more brackets in here. So I can say like,
multiplied by y, times y, okay? Like, get out
as many brackets and layers as you want. And
that's totally acceptable. And that totally works.
Okay. So now, we are going to talk about division
more specifically, and then go into a few more
operators because division works a little bit
different. In Java, is it just in general, okay.
So if I want to divide 56 by seven, so I want to
divide Zed by y, okay? And I some just do you,
okay? I'm going to call this year, and I print
this out to the screen. 56 divided by seven, gives
me a value of eight. That is because our data type
for the variable u, which is holding the value of
Zed and y, or is that divided by y is an integer.
So it actually isn't able to give us a floating
point number, although we know that this number
is a floating point number, or is it a? Let's
see, let's make sure this is not messed up. 57
divided by this guy. Yeah, so we can't give us a
floating point number because this is well an int
datatype. So it assumes that we want an integer
in return. So therefore just going to give us the
value and terminate all the decimals guy. So say
this numbers like eight point something just gives
us eight, right? removes the remainder. Now if
I want to get decimal points, what you will want
to do most the time, I could try to do something
like this. Okay, double of u equals Zed divided
by y. And you mean Okay, that makes sense double
like it's going to give us the floating point.
But watch what happens around this, we just get a
point out, well, we know that 57 divided by seven
is not 8.0. It has some decimal component to it
that I couldn't tell you right now. But why aren't
we getting that? Well, that is because the two
data types that we are dividing are both integers,
which means when we get a value back from this,
it's going to be an integer value. And then all we
do is convert it into double because we have this
double here. Okay? Just by adding that dot zero,
so how can we ensure that we get a floating point?
Well, there's two things we could do, we could
first change the bottom to be a double. And we
could change the top to be a double. So I could
do like this, it's like double. And I could change
this to be a double. Alright, and if we have both
of these double, and we try this, now I can
see that we get our decimal point, okay? And it
shows up and gives us like, whatever that is. Now,
what if I just make one of these, so I say int y,
and this is double i'd let's try this. Now, you
can see we still get our floating point. That is,
because if one of the values that we're dividing
here is a double, it's going to automatically make
the whole thing a double. So one of them is a
double, everything becomes a double. And this
is the way it works for all the operations. So if
you have double u, and in this case, we say like
x times y, or let's say x times Zed, since Zed is
a double x is not, we're still gonna get a double
value. So if we run this, you can see that we get
this little point oh, so if one of our operands is
a double, then that means everything is going to
be a double when we use it or whatever. Okay. Now,
exponent, whether we can explain it is we have
to bring in module I believe, but it's like math
dot how. And then in here, you put the, what do
you call it, the base and the exponent, there's
not a star star like in most languages, okay. I'm
gonna say, instead of D is equal to math dot pal.
And here, I'm simply going to raise x to the power
y. Alright, so we get math dot pow, let's see what
is it saying? convert doc. So let's do this. int,
int, int. cannot convert form double to form. It's
interesting why it's telling you that let's just
try this maybe. There we go. Okay, so whenever we
get X, X, exponents, apparently they have to be
in the form double. Okay, I didn't know that. But
all right. So now if I want to print out D, what's
going to happen is we get the exponent for this,
okay? So math dot pow, this is your base. And
this is what you're raising the quantity. So
five to the seven apparently is equal to that.
Okay, so that is pretty much it for operators,
I guess. Obviously, you can have as many operators
in one line as you want, you now understand how
things work in terms of doubles. And instead
of one of the operators in the whole chain of
operators that are operators variables that you're
adding, subtracting dividing whatever is a double,
then that means you're going to get a double
value back for 100%. If all of them are integers,
that means you're going to get an integer value
back out, same thing here. So I have, let's change
y back to double. And let's change you to be int.
Okay, so it says int you x times set. So now,
that's x times x times y. Okay, so now you can see
we're getting an error here, cannot convert from
double to Ent. And that is because we're trying
to say that the integer u is equal to x times y,
but y is a double value. So when we get a value
back here, it's going to be double. So we can't
convert that into an integer just by doing this.
And there's another way that we can do it that I'm
going to show you in a second, okay. So we would
have to make sure that this stays testable. And
it's nice in this ID, it tells you when you made
a mistake like that because a lot of times you
might not really see that in your program. Okay,
now I'm quickly going to go over something called
typecasting. We're going to talk about this
a lot more later. But I'm just going to show
you like fairly quickly how this works. I'm
just gonna delete this line. And we're going
to turn these back into integers. Okay, so if I
want to do something like x divided by y, okay,
and I want to make sure that I'm getting that
value, right, the decimal point value, okay, like
so a double, rather than converting these like the
declaration of a variable to a double. So maybe we
can do called typecasting and to typecast, we are
changing inline, without changing the declaration,
the type of the variable, the way to do this is
to simply put in brackets, the type that you want
to convert your variable into, and then directly
afterwards is the variable you want to convert.
So in this case, it's double. And then we have y.
Okay, so if I run this now, and I print u, instead
of D, you can see that we get the decimal value
that we were looking for. If I remove this double,
right, then we do not get that or we do just go
to those double, but you guys see the point. Okay.
So in this video, I'm just gonna be teaching you
one more operator that I forgot to mention in the
last video. And we're gonna be talking about
getting input from the user using something
called a scanner. Now this scanner is going to
allow us to grab like text, numbers, strings,
all that fun stuff from the user and then do
something with that input. And that is kind of the
basis of progress. All right, based on what a user
does, we want to do something in most cases. So,
first thing that we're going to do is just teach
this other operator, it is the remainder operator
still going to take the very long excuse, I'm just
gonna say int x is equal to 56. modulus. And this
is what the name of the operator is modulus,
it's simply a percent sign, pick a number. In
this case, I'm gonna pick five. Okay, so what this
remainder operator does, it's called the modulus.
Okay? Some people like to call a remainder
operator, and it's simply a percent sign gives
us the remainder of this division. So this
division is actually equal to, would you call
it 36 divided by five should give us 11? Okay, 11
remainder one is what this division actually is
equal to. So if we print x, we should get a value
of one. And there we go. And that's literally all
the remainder operator is gives you the remainder
of a division. I don't think I need to talk about
it too much more, I'm sure you guys want to get
into the input. So I will leave that alone for
now. Okay, so let's get rid of this line. And now
let's talk about how we can get input. So using a
scanner is what we're going to do so well, first
thing we need to actually do is at the top of your
program, you'll notice I have a new line here that
says import Java dot util dot scanner. I need you
guys to type this out for me, Java dot util dot
scanner, make sure you add your semicolon, because
this is what we're going to be using to get input.
And whenever we use certain tools in Java, we need
to import them at the top of our program so that
we can simply just type like certain data types.
And we'll get into this later when we talk about
classes and methods and all that stuff. Okay,
so once we've done that, we need to set up a
new scanner object. So we're gonna type scanner,
the name of the scanner, I'm just gonna say SC is
equal to a new scanner. And inside of the scanner,
we're gonna type System dot gains brackets. This
might seem confusing, but also is doing is it
saying scanner is a dump type just like string
as the data type, just like boolean data, okay,
it's a different type of data type, but it is in
a data type. Its name is sc. And instead of typing
like one, or like putting quotation marks and
typing a string, we're gonna say what's equal to
a new scanner. And what the scanner is going to be
is system.in, which means typing on your keyboard.
And there's different types of scanners, which
we'll get into later, not in this video. So once
we've set up our scanner, we need to actually use
the scanner. So how can we do this? So what I'm
going to type now is I'm going to say string scan
is equal to sc dot next. And I think we can just
use next Yep. So what this does is we're creating
a new variable string, it's called or it's a
string type called scan. And it is going to get
the next stream of input from the scanner object.
Okay, so SC dot next is what allows us to get a
string from the user. So I'm just going to print
out scans after we get it because I want to show
you what happens. I'm just gonna run the program
and illustrate and we'll talk about it. So now
you can see if I go down here, my cursor shows up,
I'm able to type this because when type will
Okay, watch, watch runs. When I hit Enter,
it prints Hello, underneath it. So hello, which
we typed in was the input. You got scanned in by
the scanner object using SC dot next, it got
stored in the variable scanned, and then we
were able to print scan out to the screen. Okay.
Pretty straightforward. That's how it works with
strings. Now watch this. If I type one, one works
fine. But I just need to show you that now I'm
going to do this with the MTA. So I'm gonna say
int scan equals SC dot Next, well, what's what's
happening? What's wrong? Well, the issue right
now is we are trying to turn a string which is,
which is what this returns to us into an integer.
So we can't actually do that. Because what per
se would proceed, we just run into an error,
we cannot convert from string to int, because
what this method gives us is a string. Now, if we
wanted to be able to get an integer from the user,
for them typing, we have to use a another method,
okay. And this one is called next it. Now you can
see we're getting no more red lines, everything
seems to be working fine. sc dot next int. And if
we run this, then we type like 54. That works fine
prints that out for us. What would happen? So if
I try to type in something like Hello, so there's
no errors right now, like Java is not telling us
there's anything wrong. If I type Hello, we get an
issue. Now that's because this was expecting me to
type in a integer. And what happens in here like
this little line of code, what it actually does,
is it tries to convert what I'm typing in,
which automatically comes in as a string into an
integer. So when it tried to do this, it tried to
convert Hello into an integer and no one not you,
not you, not you or me knows how to convert
Hello into an integer so it threw us an error.
So now that that's not allowed, you can't do that.
So I'll show you what we can do now if we want to
get Booleans and other types, and I'll show you
a way to work around an error like this. Okay?
So if we want to get a boolean value, we could
type Boolean scan equals Next, add, what do you
look at this Boolean? That's literally the name to
get a Boolean SC next Boolean. Okay. So let's run
this. Now, note a Boolean has to be true. spelled
correctly or false with lowercase is I'm pretty
sure. So true, that works fine. But if I try to
type like Hello, or five or something in there,
that's gonna crash, it's going to give us an
issue. Okay? So Boolean lets you do that one,
once you get a double could do double equals
next. And guess what this one is? Next double,
there you go. And now it's going to expect a
number of some sorts, like six would work fine,
but I'm going to undo 6.3. And it prints out
6.3. Let's actually just test six at six. Yeah,
just give us 6.0. So that works fine. Okay, to
getting doubles. Now, I want to work around the
issue of what happens like we get that crash,
okay, we don't we don't want that crash. So
how can we fix that if we're per se, when it's
expecting a double, I type in like, hello. Well,
what we should do is always get a string. So we
should always say a C dot next. And always turn
this into a string. And that's because a string
can be anything like anything we type in here is
fine to be a string, because remember, a string
is simply anything in double quotation marks. So
if I type true, although Yeah, we know it's a
Boolean, it's in the quotation marks. So it's
really a string. Okay? If I type one, that's a
string, type 1.6, it's a string, like anything
can be converted into a string, pretty much. So
that works fine for us. Now, once we have it as
a string, we can then convert it into an integer.
Sorry, I had to see a quick cut there. But what
we're going to do now is we're going to attempt
to convert this value into a different type. So
in our case, I want to convert it into an integer.
So the way that we can do that is we first need
to set up a variable. So I'm gonna say index
in this case, is equal to scan. Now, I'm going
to put something with this scan, I can't just say
index equals scan, I can't, I can't just do that,
it's not just gonna be able to convert that for
me, it doesn't know how to do that. So what we
need to do here is actually do dots, and are
certainly to type here. integer dot parse, int,
okay. And then inside of the brackets for parse
int, we're going to put scanned, and what this
is going to allow us to do is well convert into an
integer. And if you guys just highlight over this,
you don't know what it does, you can actually
read through the definition. So in this case,
it's going to say parses the string argument
as a signed decimal integer, the character in
the string must be old decimal digits, except the
first character may be an ASCII minus sign. Okay,
so we can tell you it tells you exactly what this
does, it tells you what integer does integers a
class. So yeah, it'll convert that for us, so
that if I wanted to print x to the screen, that
would work fine. Now, the thing is that when this
is what we're gonna be doing in the next video,
is, we still run into the same issue because
again, like now, if I type something like Hello,
we still get a crash, because how do we can
convert Hello into an integer? Well, we should
really first check if the value is an integer.
And I'm going to be showing you in the next video,
I believe, the next one or the one after that, how
we can actually do that using if statements and
else statements and error catching later on. So
stay tuned for that. But this is the way for right
now. If you know, you're going to be getting an
integer that you can convert it in, or obviously
you could just do next int and turn this to an
int like that, and everything works fine for you.
So in this video, we're going to be
talking about comparison operators,
like greater than less than or equal to not really
talking about chaining conditionals together,
which you'll see if you don't really understand
what it is right now throughout the video,
and how we can use those Boolean variables to do
certain things for us. So that's what we talked
about in the first few videos. And if you guys
don't really know what the point of Boolean is,
well, this video will show you. So without further
ado, let's get started. So I'm just going to start
off by typing a few numbers here because it's
just the easiest way to compare things to start,
and then we'll do some other stuff. So I'm going
to create three variables that are integers.
X is six, y is seven ends, that is 10. Now I'm
going to create a boolean variable. So Boolean,
else, call it compare, and we'll just set that
blank for right now. So what I want to do is I
want to compare x and y and Zed using some
different comparison operators. So in Java,
I'm going to write them out here. We have a belief
for main comparison operators four or five. So
we'll type them out and we can see, so the first
one is greater than, and then we have less than
we have equal to, oops, we have greater than or
equal to less than or equal to and not equal to.
Now I know I just went through those fast but
they're pretty straightforward, this is simply
going to state whether something is greater than
the other thing, this is less than the other thing
or whatever way you have it right? This is, is
equal to so the double equal sign is different
than the single equal sign, double equal sign is
when you're comparing two values to see if they're
the same. And the single equal sign like this one
here, is if you're assigning a value, so make sure
you remember that because a lot of people when
they compare things, they forget to add the other
equal sign, and they just use one and they end up
running into some issues. Okay, so greater than
or equal to pretty straightforward, less than
or equal to same thing and not equal to as an
exclamation point and an equal sign. Now I'm going
to go through these and show what all these do. So
I saw Actually, I'll leave that there. And because
I just remember that I have been forgetting to
teach you this. If you do two slashes in Java,
this stands for a comment. And a comment is simply
something that the computer is going to ignore.
And it's just there for the programmer. So they
can look at it and be like, Okay, this is what
this line of code does. Whatever the computer
doesn't care, so whenever it sees a line that
has starts with two slashes, this is how you do
a comment. It just ignores that line and moves
on. So that's simply what a comment is. And it
just Gray's out in here to show us that that's a
comment. Okay, so compare. So I want to compare x
and y. And I want to set see if x is less than
y. So say, if x is less than y, and what this
statement right here that we're typing here is
going to return a value of either true or false.
So we can look at this, we say, well, six is not
less than seven. Yes, it is. So that should give
us a value of true. So if we print compared to the
screen, then you can see we get true like that.
Now, if I flip this around, and I say greater
than, okay, what do you think we're going to get?
Well, we get false, it's pretty straightforward to
compare the two values to see if they're the same,
we can do two equal signs. And in this case, we
get false. And now this this comparison operator,
some people get confused by. But if I do not
equal to, what this is going to tell me is if
the two values on the left side and the right side
of the comparison operator are not the same, so if
they're not the same, I get true. If they are the
same, I get false. So in this case, they're not
the same. So we should be getting true. Okay. And
I guess I can show you greater than or equal to,
but they're pretty straightforward in terms of
how they work, at least on numbers. Okay? Now,
these work fine. So greater than or equal to less
than or equal to on numbers. But what if I want
to compare strings, so I'm just going to change x
and y, I'm gonna make two strings here. I'll say,
oops, string, x, will say hello, and string
y. And this is equal to pi. Okay? So see,
now I'm getting this blurred out, or this red
line here, it's saying the comparison operator
greater than or equal to undefined for strings. So
the only ones that I'm allowed to do on strings,
at least for right now that we're going to talk
about, are two equal signs, or not equal to,
okay? And not equal to is simply going to say,
right, if the strings are not the same, and if
they are the same, so in this case, I say not the
same, I'm gonna get true. If I try to see say,
if they are the same, I get false. Now, I want you
to just show you one thing here, if I type Hello,
and I add a capital O at the end of Hello like
this, do we think that this is the same as Hello
with all lower cases are not? Well, I'll show
you. It is not so capital letters do matter. In
program, right, let's assume with variable names,
like the capital variable Y is different than the
lowercase variable y. Okay, so that's how we
can compare those. And I want to see actually,
can we use greater than net, we can't use
greater than or less than on strings either.
Okay. So what I'm going to do now is I want to
chain multiple conditions together. So I'm going
to show you the end operator, the OR operator,
and the NOT operator. And these are how we can
add multiple conditions together to get one
like main condition. If that makes sense,
I'm going to change these back to two numbers
might be faster just to type them out. index
equals what I have six into y equals, let's just
do like 23. Why not? Okay, so now I'm going to
compare multiple things at once. So I first want
to compare if x is greater than y, but I also want
to compare if Zed is greater than x, say I want to
check two things perfectly viable. In many cases,
you'd want to do that. The way that we can do that
in Java to compare if two things are the same,
is using this an operator AND AND operator is
looks like this. So it's these two and signs,
okay? And then we have to add another condition
after this. In this case, I'm going to say if
Zed is arch, say Zed is less than y, okay? You can
see that's fine. We're not getting any red lines.
And what this does is it's going to compare the
operation on the left side, it's going to do the
comparison on the right side, and then we're going
to end up getting two values. So in this case,
x is greater than y. So six, is that greater than
y? No, we're gonna get false. So I'll just type
it out as if this is what's happening in the
computer, right? And that is less than y. Yes,
it is. So we get true like this, okay? Now, we
have a false and we have a true, but we have
this and operator in between them. What this and
operators can do is it's going to check if both of
the conditions on the left side and the right side
are true. If they're both true, it returns true to
us. If they're both pretty one of them is false,
or both of them are false, then we get a false
value. So in this case, since this one is false,
we're going to get a false value because both of
them have to be true for this to evaluate to true.
So I'll show you if I do this. Okay, and I print
this to the screen, you can see we get a false
value, because this is saying, if this and this
are true, then the whole thing is true. Okay. Now
another operator that we have is the OR operator.
And the OR operator is to straight up lines like
this, I don't know what they're actually called,
the key for that, but anyways, so this is gonna do
kind of, it's similar to end. But in the other way
around, if one of the two conditions are true,
the whole thing is going to be true. Otherwise,
if both of them are false, it's false, right?
So the way that we can determine this again,
right is we'll do this condition, we'll see what
this is equal to, and then we'll see what this
is equal to. And if one of them are true, we get a
true value. So let's run and there we go, you see,
we get a true value. Now, we have a knot operator.
Now what not does is simply going to reverse
anything. And this is what I like to think about
it, whatever you have, if you see the knot, just
reverse it. So what this does is it's going to say
if this condition is not true, then we get false.
Or if this condition is false or not true, then
we get true other way around. If this condition
is true, then it's false. Because it's checking if
it's not true, I hope that makes sense, you kind
of just have to play with it to make sense of it.
But in this case, since we get a true value, and
we have this exclamation point, which is our NOT
operator is going to give us false. So you can see
here we get false. Now if in here I were to put a
false value. So let's literally I'll just show you
by typing in the value, I say not and then false
in there, you can see that we get a true value.
So it's simply just reverses like anything that
you're looking at. Now I want to show you that
we can actually combined all of these operators
together. So what we can do is we can use like
ands and ORS and we can have an infinitely
long chain of a condition that will eventually
evaluate to true. Now this is actually some kind
of like math problems you have to do typically in
university, I'm gonna have to do it next semester,
where you have like a ton of different conditions,
and you have to figure out if you're going to
get true or false based on them. So I'll show
you like a pretty basic example. So I'll say if x
is less than y, and y is greater than Zed, or Zed
plus two is less than five. Or what do you call
it? Like x plus seven is greater than what? Okay,
so I just typed a bunch of conditions, right?
How do we determine which ones which of these
are going to evaluate first? Well, that is a good
question. And typically, you'd never type it like
this. Because just looking at this, like even
I'm looking at it right now after I just typed
it in. I'm like, wow, okay, how do I determine
which one of these is going to happen first,
typically, you put things in brackets, so I would
say something like this. It's like x and y. Okay,
so I have this first conditional, right? You put
in brackets, it's going to evaluate this, and in
this case, we'll get I'm not going to bother doing
the actual evaluation. But let's say we get true,
okay? Or so we have true, or whatever this
evaluated with this is. So what this is
going to do now is it's going to look at said plus
two, if that's less than five, if that's true,
then we get true or and then whatever this is,
and then we could treat this as if this is in
brackets like this. Okay. So now the way that this
would work, is we do everything in brackets here,
we get a value of like true or false. We do
everything in brackets here, we get a value of
true or false. And then we'd see if either of them
are true, and return that value. So you know what,
let's just print it to see what we get. If we get
true, okay, I don't even know how that worked to
be honest. And yeah, that's how we could do
that. And we can also throw knots in here
too. So if I want to throw a knot like this,
then we can do that. Now typically, you're not
going to see massive chain conditionals like this,
because of the exact problem we're running into,
it's difficult to determine what they are by just
reading it. And you'll see when we go into if
and else statements in the next video how we can
use these conditions to evaluate certain things,
I just wanted to show you that you can combine
multiple things. And for example, I don't only
have to use variables, you can see that here I put
Zed plus two less than five, that's a perfectly
valid condition that works perfectly fine, can
change this is equal to five, right? And you can
add constants, like I could just say two is equal
to five if I want it to, but that's fine. You can
compare with constants. And with strings, just
remember you can do less than or equal to, or
sorry, not less than not the not equal to or equal
to, and you can compare floats with intz. And
you'll see as we continue going through the video,
it's too long to go through all them right now.
In this video, we're going to be going over if,
else and Elif statements in Java. So quickly,
just I want to fix a really small mistake I made
in the last video. So if you guys don't know,
I am like a Python programmer typically. So I'm
doing Java, obviously. But Python is like my
first language. So I'm used to being able to use
two equal signs on pretty much anything because
that's what you can do in Python. But in the
last video, I showed you using two equal signs
on strings. Now, that's not incorrect to do that,
but it's not going to work the way you think right
now. So if you want to compare if two strings are
logically the same, like the actual string values
have the same, what you should actually do is say
you have a string. So in this case, you have to
do dot equals Okay. And then inside of this equals
here, you're going to put the string that you want
to compare it to, or you're going to put another
variable, which is a string. So in this case,
I want to say if like, my scanner object, which
I've just typed out before this video, is equal
to Hello, this is how I would do it with this dot
equal sign, not the two equal signs, you the two
equal signs isn't wrong, but it's going to give
you a different answer. And we will talk about
that in future videos, but it's too advanced to go
into right now. So just remember, if you want to
compare two strings, use dot equals My apologies
about that from the last video. So what we want to
do now is we're going to do it using if and else
statements. So pretty much if something happens,
do this, otherwise, do this. And this is the
basis of programming. Using conditions based
on like user input, or based on certain events
that happened, we're gonna do different things,
right? So they're really important to understand.
So first of all, what I'm doing here is I'm just
getting, I'm just setting up a new scanner object,
I'm just going to get input from the user, we've
already talked about this. And what I want to do
is I want to check that user's input, and based
on what they type in, I want to do something.
So the basic syntax for if analysis in Java is
you simply type if you put brackets, and inside
of these brackets is going to be your condition.
And this is why I spend so much time talking about
conditions the last video, the condition here is
if this condition evaluates to true, whatever's
inside of what I'm going to show you here,
whatever's inside of these curly braces is going
to happen. So let's start with the condition. When
I say if s dot equals not two equal signs, and
in this case, I'm going to say, Tim. So if the
user types in Tim, when we're when we prompt them
for input, then I want to do something. And what's
going to happen is inside of these curly braces,
and this denotes a block. So this is known as like
an if statement, or an IF block. So this block
simply goes to syntax, if then we have this,
these brackets inside the brackets as a condition,
the condition can be as long as it wants as long
as you want, as long as you're going to get a
true or false value back from it. And then we
have these curly braces, so an open brace and a
closed brace. And inside of these braces, anything
that I typed in here is going to happen if this
condition is true. So let's just do a quick little
test here. And I'm going to do system dot out.
dot print ln. And in this case, we'll just say,
you typed Tim, okay, what types you types? you
typed Tim? Okay. And let's run the program and
see what happens. So when I run this, if it loads
up, That's odd. Okay. Give me one second. Okay,
so we're back, I accidentally closed my console.
And yeah, we running into some issues with that.
So I got that up and running now. Let me
just restart this quickly. Okay. Wow, okay.
I don't know why. That's why But anyways, let's
just type out. What are we going to say here,
let's type hello and see what we get? Well, we get
nothing because we didn't type Tim. So let's run
it again. Let's try it. And this time I type Tim,
and it says, you typed Tim. So there we go, our
basic if statement is working. Now I want you to
just put another system dot out over here so that
we can see what happens when we have like just
with this example. Okay, I'm just going to print,
I'm literally going to print print. Okay. So now
what I want to show, what happens here is like,
what is the program going to run? So if we type
Tim, we're gonna get this you type Tim. But are
we still going to get this print out here? Or are
we not going to get it? Well, let's test this out
and see, okay, so in this case, I typed Tim. So
when I typed him, it says you type Tim and then
it says print, okay? Now the reason that happens
is because this print is not within this if block,
right? So we're just going to execute simply
after this if block happens now, same thing,
right? If I type, like Hi, it's still going to
print out print to the screen. Because right?
It didn't go through this if block but this is
not inside of the if block or the if statement
or whatever. So that executes. Okay, so that's
pretty straightforward. Now I'm going to show
you else and elsket rest start with else. So else
is very straightforward. It can only come after,
and else if or and if so, like the start of
the block has to be if and then this else You
can't just have it like alone. It has to come
after an if statement or an elsif statement,
which we're going to go into in a second. Okay.
There's different ways to format this. Some people
like to put the else like this Has the closing
brace than the open brace. I personally like
to do it like this. Some people like to do it like
this, it's however you want, okay? This just works
fine. Just make sure that your curly brace doesn't
look something like that all the way up there,
because that's kind of hard to read. Okay. So
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to put this
print statement, and I'm going to put it in my elf
statement, right? Now, the way this else works is,
if this happens, that's fine. We're going to go
in here, we're going to print this out, and then
we'll move down to the end of the block. So we'll
go to here as our next execution line. Now, if
this doesn't happen, so other words, or else, then
we print this, so we're either printing you type
Tim or print, we're never printing both because
one of them is if and one of themselves. Alright,
so let's test this out. If I type Tim, we you type
Tim. Okay, if I type anything else, so like some
random letters, and I hit Enter, you get print.
So is LS works is it's meant to do something if
this condition is not true, right? Okay, so that's
pretty straightforward. I don't think any to talk
about that anymore. The next one I'm going to
show you is elsif. Now this is a way that we can
add multiple if conditions in one kind of block.
Okay, so what I can do now is I can do like elsif.
And now it's the exact same syntax as regular if
statement, except you just have this else before.
And obviously, since this is an else it has to
come after an initial if statement. So you can
have as many of these else ifs as you want. Now,
first, I'll just put a condition in here. So say,
s dot equals, and in this case, let's just say
like, Hello, okay. And then in here, we'll just do
system, dot out, dot print, ln, and we'll just say
hi, because we want to greet them back. They said,
Hello. Okay, so again, the way this is gonna work,
is we're gonna go through, we're gonna check,
we're gonna get our scanner input, we get
us say, okay, what's s is s equal to Tim,
if it is we're gonna print this, and then we're
gonna move down after the last l statement,
we're not going to even bother checking if it's
something else, because if it's equal to Tim,
then we know that we shouldn't bother looking at
the L sips. Right. Now, if it's not equal to Tim,
what we're going to do is we're going to go
through and we're going to check reinstate k LS F,
that's our next block, is it equal to Hello,
if it's equal to Hello, we're gonna print Hi,
we're gonna move on with our lives, you're gonna
move down here, we're not even going to bother
going to the else. Okay? Now, if it's not equal to
Hello, we're going to go into the else statement.
And we're just simply going to print print,
there's no condition, it just automatically
going to happen. If you print anything other than
Hello, or Tim, we're going to print print. Okay,
so let's try this out. And let's type Hello.
And you can see we get Hi, all right. Now,
if I print type anything else in here, like some
random letters, we get print. Okay. And that is
how that works. Now I can show you I can add as
many else ifs as I want. So if I copy this, and I
simply paste it down here, gonna have another LCF.
And in here, I could have Hi. And then in here,
I could type Hello. And we could keep going.
We could do as many else ifs, as we want. Just
know that whenever you have a kind of a block
that looks like this, it has to start with an
if statement. And it does actually doesn't have to
end with an else. So in else just is should be the
last thing so if you have any else ifs else will
be your last thing like I couldn't do an lF here,
and then try typing like that's, that's not
okay, you can't do that. But if I omit this else,
that's perfectly fine. So now I have if we type
Tim, we type Hello, or we type Hi, let's run this.
And let's type none of them. Let's, let's type a
bunch of letters, we get nothing printed to the
screen because we don't have that l statement.
Now, if I type Hi, you see we get Hello. Because
right we went through wasn't equal to Tim. It
wasn't equal to Hello. So we printed Hi. Now
I want to show you this. This is a bad example.
But it it'll work. If I put Hello here. And I put
Hello here. Which one are we going to print? So
remember, we're only going to print one of these
things. We're not going to print more than one.
So which one? Is it high? Or is it Hello? Well,
let's test it out. If I type Hello in here, we
print high. Now the reason we're printing high
is because this else if is above this one, and
this is the first one that's going to be looked
at when we type something in just the way I kind
of went through it sequentially. So since we print
high here, we're like, Okay, well that happened.
So there's no point in checking this. And we just
move on. Okay, straightforward. Now again, I could
do more if statements down here, you could keep
typing like do a bunch of stuff, just understand
you can have as many elsif as you want. You don't
need to know stuff. Like we could just do an IF
and then else. But every time you have kind of
like an if statement or block starting it has to
start with an if it could have as many elesis as
you want. And the last thing has to be an else.
If you're adding else you don't have to have that
else there. So anyways, I think that's all I'm
going to show for if statements elsif and else
they're pretty straightforward. Any condition can
go here. So anything that I showed you before,
like you could have a really long chain
conditional a ton of stuff. Same thing here,
you could have any condition like it doesn't
matter, anything that gives you true or false
value, you could also literally just type
true. And like that would always happen, okay?
In this video, we're going to be kind of taking
a step back and just going through everything
that we've already learned summarizing that,
putting that into a program to make sure that
you guys really understand all of that. And we're
also gonna be talking about nested statements. So
how you can kind of add things within other things
like so if statements within other if statements
variables. And the way I'm going to do this
is just by creating a simple program. And what
it's going to do is it's going to ask the user to
input their age. And then based on that age, we're
going to do certain things with that, we're going
to tell them like, I don't know good examples,
like on a roller coaster, like if you're 13 or
older, you can ride otherwise you can, so we're
going to do something like that. Okay, so I'm
going to keep these scanners up here that I have,
because we want to get the user's age. But um,
first, before I set up the scanner is I'm just
going to print a line to the screen here. So
I'm just going to say system, dot out dot print,
and so print ln. And in this case, I will just
say, input your age simply okay? So this way,
it should, if I'm doing this correctly, make
it so that we just get the age right after this
line. Okay, you'll you'll see when we do that in
a second. Anyways, what I'm going to do now is I'm
just going to kind of start typing, and we'll go
through how this works out. So I'm gonna say if,
and we're actually just going to convert this
to int first, I think string to an int. Yeah,
so using that parse into that I was talking about,
so we'll say int, age is equal to s.or integer,
I always forget how to do this integer dot
parse int. And then in here, we need to type s,
so we're going to convert whatever they type
into an integer in this case, so we're going
to assume that they type in an integer. So we'll
say if age is greater than or equal to 13, then
we will simply print System dot out dot print,
ln. You can write Okay, exclamation point. Now,
if they're not older than 13, that must mean
that they are less than 13 or younger than 13.
So in this case, we will simply print that they
cannot write system dot out. dot print ln. And
you cannot write exclamation point. Okay, pretty
basic program, we kind of have gone through all
this work. So let's test it out. input your age
five, you cannot ride. Okay, let's try this now.
input your age 43. You can ride awesome. Okay,
so everything's working fine for right now. Now
what I'm going to do is I am going to add a elsif
here and I'm going to change kind of the problem
that we're looking at. So I'm going to say now I
want to classify the person based on their age as
either an adult, a teenager, or just like younger
than a teenager. Okay? I don't know, what do you
call those? Whatever, younger than teenagers.
Okay, so if we are greater than or equal to 18,
I want to print you are an adult, okay? Now
otherwise, so if they are not greater than 18,
we want to check if they are less than 18. So or
if they're, actually we'll do it in a in a cool
way, that's gonna make sense here in a second. So
else, if age is not greater than or equal to 18,
we know it's less than 18. So all we actually
have to check is if they are older than 13,
right? We're greater or older than or equal to 13?
Because that's what a teenager would be. And the
reason we don't have to check if they are, what
do you call it younger is, or if they're older,
is because we already know that they're gonna
be younger than 18. So know where they're at
within that range. So I already butchered that
explanation, but that's okay. So system, dot out
dot print, ln. And in this case, we'll just say
you are a teenager, okay, like that. And then in
this last case, well, we know they're not older
than or equal to 18. We know they're not older
than or equal to 30. And that meaning they must
be less than which is you are not a teenager or an
adult, okay, like that. So let's test our program
out, make sure everything is working. So if we
input an age of 14, we get you are a teenager.
Awesome. Okay, let's try it again. We input an
age of 19. Get you're an adult. And if we input an
age of zero, yet, you are not a teenager, we're an
adult. Now, I want to show you what happens if
I input like a negative number, like what if I
do like negative 98? You are not a teenager or an
adult because right we have this L statement. And
that's not greater than or equal to 13. It's not
greater than or equal to 18. So we get you're not
a teenager or an adult. Okay. Now, that is pretty
straightforward. What I'm going to show you now
is how we can ask like another question or how we
can check something else. So what I'm going to do
here is I want to say, if they're 18, and only
if they're 18. Want to ask them a question?
What should the question be? I want to ask them
what their favorite food is. Okay? So I'm simply
going to do now exactly what I've done up here,
except just throw it inside of this if statement.
So if this happens, we're going to do this and
this is going to show you nesting. Okay? So we're
gonna say SC, or we'll say, string is Windows to
integers. We're gonna assume that our string and
guess Kazumi food Yeah, we'll say string. Food
is equal to SC, dot next line, like this, okay?
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to print
up here again, what we're looking for, so I'll
just copy this in a second. And in this case, I'll
say, input your fav food, okay? Now what I want to
do is I want to check what their favorite food is.
So I want to say if their favorite food is pizza,
I'll say mine too. Otherwise, we'll say that's
not my favorite food or something like that. Okay,
we'll say if, and we have our conditioning here,
we'll say if food dot equals, and in this case,
we'll simply type pizza. Right? Then we will
system dot out, dot print, ln. And we'll say
mine. Wow, inside of the coats, hopefully. Say
mine too. And then otherwise, so the else, what
we'll do is we'll simply type system, dot out dot
print, ln. And in this case, we'll say, not mine.
Okay? So this is showing you now it looks a bit
more complicated, but that we can actually put if
statements and else statements, we can do things
with inside of the if statement. And I'll show you
that this works. So if I type, I'm 19. It's gonna
say input your fav food, okay, my favorite food,
let's try pizza, says mine too. Awesome. That's
working. Now, if I type something else, so I typed
like for, it just tells me I'm not a teenager,
and adult because we don't have anything else
happening inside of this if statement, or this
else over here. Okay. Now, that's really cool.
And that allows us to do some neat things. And
you can continually nest This is called nesting,
putting a statement inside of another statement,
you can continue to do that as much as you want.
So I just wanted to show that to you. Because
a lot of people think that that's not possible,
they don't understand that you're able to do that,
because they haven't been shown that right? So
again, if I want to ask another question, I could
do that inside of here. And I can just keep going.
What is an array? Well, an array is a collection,
pretty much of elements, that is a set size. So
rather than having like a variable equal to one,
you'd have an array and it would have a bunch of
different values in there that you can index
at certain points. And you'll see when I start
talking about them here, if you're a little bit
confused, but how to create an array is to first
you have to declare the type that you want your
array to be. So all the values in the array,
at least right now have to be the same type. So in
this case, I'm going to create an integer array.
And to declare that this is going to be an array,
you simply do these little square brackets, use a
in square brackets, the name of your array in this
Gizmo is a new arr standing for array is equal to,
and then in this case, you're going to say new
int, square brackets. And inside of the square
brackets, you have to define how many elements or
how long your array is going to be. In this case,
I'm just gonna say five. Okay, so you can
see that's fine. not getting any issues here,
just because we're not using new AR. But yeah,
this is the syntax. So whatever type you want
it to be, you type the type. So if I wanted to
be string, I do string. And then this obviously,
would have to be the same string like that. Okay,
square brackets, name of your array equals new,
and then the type square brackets how
long you want the array to be. Now,
there's another way to declare this, I'll show
you in a second. But this is like a set length,
like you can't change this length. So you have to
make sure that when you're declaring your arrays,
you know how many elements you want to have.
Because you can't if you make an array length
zero, then there's no point in using it. You can't
add, you can't add anything past like that length,
okay? And what it's going to do is it's going
to, by default set all of these elements to like,
no, so they have no value, but they exist, like
they're there. They just aren't holding anything
right now. Okay? Well, you can kind of think of it
as you're initializing, like five containers that
are old gonna hold something, but they're not yet
holding anything. So is a good way to visualize.
So we're gonna keep the string array for now.
And I'll show you how we can add things to array
and change values and print them out and see
what that looks like. Okay, so the way that you
index things in an array and array is going to be
it's going to look like these curly braces. Okay,
so I'm just gonna type some stuff out and just
follow with merit. So my string array I want to
have Hello. I need double quotes. Hi, Tim. Maybe I
should have done last values bill, and Joe. Okay.
Now these are the five values in my string array.
This don't type this out with me. This is just
showing you an example. Now the way that we start
counting in computers are actually let's first say
this, every element in our array is going to have
an index, okay? And the index is going to be a
number that represents its position. So in this
case, you'd say like this is position one, this
is position two, and this would be position five.
Now, if I were to ask for position zero, or sorry,
position one, it would give me Hello. But the
thing is, that seems logical. But in computers,
we actually start counting at zero, meaning
that position one, which I'm saying is Hello is
actually going to be position zero. And that means
that whatever the length of my array is, the so in
this case, five, the last position in my array is
going to be the length minus one. So in this case,
four, so Joe would be position four. And these
are known as indexes, like index zero is Hello,
index one is high, index two is Tim. And this
allows us to really easily grab different elements
without having to know their value, we just know
the position of them in the array. Okay, so 01234.
That's how we count in computers. Okay, so how can
we actually access these different elements? Well,
I'm going to create a variable and just say
string x equals, and in this case, I want to
get like value two in my array. So first of all,
I haven't actually added anything to my rate, but
we'll do that in a second. But how I would do that
is I would type like new AR, and then I put square
brackets and then in here, I put the position. So
position, so I want to get Hello, I think that was
the first or second position I will see anyways,
I would type one. And what this would give me is
the second value in my array, because remember, we
start counting at zero, so the first value would
be zero, and the last value would be four. Now
maybe this is going to look a little easier once I
start adding things into my array. So the way that
we can actually add things into the array is what
we've declared an array and we set it has length
five, which means that these elements already
exists, or those buckets, there's not holding
anything. So what we have to do is we have to
say new AR zero is equal to, and in this case,
let's give it a value. So let's say hello, okay,
put our semicolon, there we go. We've just set
position zero, index, zero, whatever, to Hello.
Okay, so now if I copy this a few times, I can
set the values of all the elements in my array. So
I did 012, and three, and here, I can just change
these. So say hi, I'll say, Tim, I will say, Bill.
And we can add one more, but we don't have to. So
if we let's, let's just add one more for the sake
of it. And new AR four is equal to what we call it
geo up. I don't know why it's doing that for me.
Okay, jus like that. Alright, so it may say string
x equals new AR four, then that's going to be
equal to Joe. So to print this out to the screen,
now I can do system dot out, dot print, ln. And in
this case, I will say x, and let's see what we
get. We get Joe, right, because we added all of
these into the array. Now if I just comment this
out by doing that, let's see what happens when
we do a new AR for let's see what we get, we get
no, now that's because remember what I said when
we initialize this array, we set it of a length of
five and we say we Okay, these are our containers,
we've got five containers, five buckets, they're
gonna hold values, we don't know what the values
are yet. Alright. So if we haven't set a value
for the fourth index, or the fourth position,
well, we don't know what it is. So we're just
going to return no meaning nothing is there
right now. Okay. So yeah, so those are, that's
how you add things into an array. Now there's,
I'm going to create another array and show you a
kind of an easier way to do this, if you're just
gonna like statically type in numbers, okay,
so I'm gonna say int summary into an integer
edge to save me from doing all these quotation
marks, I'm gonna say, and let's say num is equal
to new it square brackets. Or actually, we don't
need that, because we're gonna do the other way,
we're just gonna put two curly braces. And in
here, we're going to type out our array. So in
this case, this is now my number array. So I put
it in curly braces, and I have an array of two
354, six and six. Now again, just to recap, two
would be at index 03 would be at index one, okay?
Because that's where we start counting. And now,
if I wanted to, instead of having x equal to new
error, I'm going to say nums four, which should
be six, right? And what's our error here? Change,
this has to be an int, my bad. index equals lumps
four, we print this out, you can see we get the
value six. So that's another way to create an
array, if you're just going to be like typing in
all of the numbers like that, okay. And obviously,
you can create arrays of different types like int,
we could do string we do float, we do double,
so you say like a double array of nums to is
equal to and then in here, like 2.0 3.0 There you
go. We now have a Wow, really forgot that. Okay,
well, you need But that works. Okay, we now have a
double array at index zero, we have 2.0. at index
one, we have 3.0. And yeah, so arrays can get
fairly complicated, they're not really the best
thing to be using for a lot of example cases. But
for right now we have to understand them. in later
videos, I'm going to be talking about collections,
which are going to allow us to do some cooler
things rather than like indexing elements like
this. There's some cool methods that we can use
on those. But for now, I would just want to
make sure that we do understand arrays, okay.
So in this video, I'm going to be talking about
for loops. Now, for loops are fundamental aspect
of every programming language. And
they're very important to understand,
I can almost guarantee you that any program you
write will use multiple for loops. So pretty much
a for loop is allows us to kind of automate a
task, do something a set amount of times. And
typically when you use a for loop, you're using
that because you know how many times you want
to do something or like a condition is going
to tell you how many times to do something as
opposed to what we're going to talk about in
future videos, which is a while loop. While
you're not really sure how long it's going to go
for. So you do something based on a condition,
but we'll talk about that when we get to it.
So let's start and just do an example of what
the for loop can really like solve for us,
for example, okay, so say this is a pretty
simple example. And you guys will see in a second
directory integer, C index equals zero and say
that I want to add one, and then I want to add
two to it. And then I want to add three to it,
and four, and five and six, and like an infinite
amount of times I want to add to that variable.
Well, we could do like x plus equals one, we could
do x plus equals to like in keep going and adding
things to x. And we could just keep copying and
pasting this down our program. But obviously,
that's terribly inefficient in terms of a typing
standpoint. And what if we wanted to change this,
what if every time we want the program, we want
to ask the user how many times they want to add
like a pattern like this to x? Well, then we would
have to constantly keep changing the numbers here,
right, so this is where for loop can kind of come
in handy. So the syntax for for that, I'm just
going to type it out, and then we will talk about
exactly what it does. So it has these brackets
here and in here, we're gonna put three things
typically, okay, so what you're gonna do is you're
going to first start off by declaring a variable.
So in this case, I'm gonna say int x is equal to
zero, okay? Now this can be called whatever you
want. Typically, people call it AI, I like to use
x, but you know, let's just use AI. And then what
you're gonna do for this next, so you're gonna put
a semicolon, and then the next thing you're gonna
do is you're going to set a condition. So I'm just
gonna do this and then talk about because it's
hard to kind of do it step by step, because they
all work together, less than or equal to 10. And
I plus plus. Okay, so what I've just done here,
actually, is I first started by declaring a
variable is equal to zero. And then I've said,
we're going to do this while i is less than or
equal to 10. And we're going to add one to I.
So pretty much the way this works, is every time
we execute what's in these little square brackets
here, is gonna have one added to it. So this is
what's known as the increment. And this comes at
the end of your for loop. So this is what you're
adding to the variable i, which you're declaring
here, every time you run the loop. Now this here
is your condition. And this is going to state how
many times a loop is gonna run. So in our case,
we're going to run the loop. And while i is less
than or equal to the value 10, meaning we're going
to start at the value zero, because I equals zero,
we're going to run this loop, then we're going to
come back up here, we're gonna say, Okay, what are
we doing? We're adding one to AI, then we're gonna
check this condition, so i is not equal to one,
we're gonna say, well, is one less than equal
to 10? No, it's not. And then we're gonna loop
through, and we're gonna continue looping through
until eventually, we get to the point where we add
to i, it's equal to 1111. Well, that's greater
than 10. So we break out of this loop, and you
guys will see when I start printing stuff to the
screen exactly how this works. But I hope that
was a decent explanation of the way to do this.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm just going to print
out here and I'm going to tell you right, now
what's going to happen, right, so we're starting
at zero. So the first loop here, where I come
through is equal to zero, we're gonna print zero,
next loop, we come up, we add one, two, I check
the condition, we're okay, we can keep going.
We're at one, and we're going to print from zero
to 10. So watch when I run here, we get zero all
the way up to 10. Okay, that's how the for loop
works. So we execute whatever is in between these
little curly braces 10 times, or 11 times in
this case, because zero to 10 is 11. Right? Now,
we can change this increment, we can change this
condition, there's a lot of things that we can
do in this for loop. So here we say for int i
equals zero, I could do for int i equals five,
and I can start at the value five and now we're
going to start we're going to go from five to 10
looping 123456 times, right? We're printing six
different values, okay? So that's if you can do
that If I tried to do something like i equals
11, well watch what happens, nothing prints to
the screen. And that's because 11, well, that's
greater than or equal to 10. So the loop doesn't
even run one time, right. So let's go back, and
let's start at zero. And now let's show what we
can do in terms of incrementing. So to increment
here, we can do i plus equals, and then any value
we want. So in this case, if I do five, we started
zero, we're going to add five, we're going to
add five again. So we get 05, and 10. And you can
change this to whatever value that you want. Okay,
same thing here with the condition. These can
also be variables, I feel like I don't need to
tell you that. But if I do something like int
x equals five, then I could do i plus equals x,
right, and we can add that integer to it, we
can add x as the bound here. So less than or
equal to this could be greater than this can be
greater than or equal to. So I'm just going to
quickly go over one thing that a lot of people
get confused with, for with for loops. And it's
when we're going to stop and when we're going to
start. So when we say less than or equal to 10,
this means we're going to start at this value. And
now assuming we're adding one, okay, we are going
to stop but include 10, meaning that I will hit
the value 10, we will print 10 to the screen. Now,
if I remove this equal sign, this is only going
to happen while i is less than 10. Which means
that if I is 10, well, 10 is not less than 10. So
we are not going to print 10. So if I run this,
you can see we only get up to the value nine. Now
the reason I'm talking about this is because what
we typically want to do with loops is we want to
loop through something or look at some data. And
typically that data is in the form of an array.
So now in the slide talked about arrays before,
I'm going to create an array, so an integer
array, let's call it Arr, is equal to, and let's
just give it some values here. So like 157345,
okay, this is going to be our integer array. Now,
what do I want to do? If or how am I going to do
this, if I want to look through my array and look
at look at these values, and maybe check them
values equal to seven or values equal to five
or something like that? Well, the way that I can
do this, and this is like a dynamic way to do it,
is I could count the length of the reg and say,
123456, guys, six elements. So I would put is less
than six year. But a more useful way to do this
is to just get the length of the array. And the
way that I can do that is just to do a arc dot
length, or I actually don't need this bracket,
sorry. So we'll just do this in this way, say the
user had typed in a bunch of elements, we had put
them in an array, we don't know how many elements
they type in, per se. So we're going to use this
length so that we can change this loop and this
loop will never crash, it will always work.
Because we're just simply getting the length of
the array. Now if I were to do equal here, I hope
you guys realized this would cause us an issue.
And that's because we have six elements in the
array, right? But it's going to allow us to get i
to the value six, because that's the length of the
array. Now what happens if I try to do this arr
of six? Well, we should know from the last video
that that will actually crash our program. And
that's because when we start we start at zero, and
our last element in the array is actually going
to be index five, right, because we go to zero
all the way to the length minus one, which is
five, so race six does not actually exist. So
what I'm going to do now, is I'm just going to
write a little program inside this for loop, and
I'm just gonna say if the value is equal to five,
we're going to print it out. So how do I do this,
I'm gonna say if arr index i is equal to the value
five, then we're simply going to be a system,
dot out dot print, ln, I just realized this comma
there, alright, semi colon, and we're simply going
to print the value. So in this case, we could
print air I, which we know is gonna be five,
or we could just type five because we know
that it's there. So in this case, let's just
do found a five exclamation point, okay, that's
what we'll print to the screen. So again, the
reason this is gonna work is because we're looping
through starting at zero, and going to but not,
but not including the length of the array, make
sure you remove that equal sign, otherwise you're
gonna get a crash, okay? So that way, we're going
to look at every single element in this array,
we're going to check its value. And then if we
find a five, we're gonna print it. So let's see
if this works. found five and found a five. Now
for wanting to be more precise, and say like where
I found this five, I could say found a five at
index, and we'll just put a plus sign and then we
can put pi. And what this is going to do is it's
actually just going to automatically convert this
into a string for us and print it out with this
index. So we're going to put a space here just
so they don't get smushed together. But it says
found a five at index one and found a five at
index five and we know this is true. Index
one is here, index five is here. And that's
a really simple way that we can loop through
a list and look for a certain value. Okay.
Well, I'm going to be showing you a different kind
of for loop which is known as a for each loop. And
this is going to allow us to loop through the
elements of a list or a collection data type,
and do something with those elements, I'm also
going to be showing you ways that we can break
out of the loop at certain points. So if the
condition is not met, or like, we just want to
get out of the loop the way that we can do that,
and I'm gonna be showing you some common examples
of where we use loops. So let's go ahead and get
started. So you can see that I have two arrays,
here one's name names, and one is named AR, I just
added this names one is just a blank, blank array
for right now. Okay, so what I first want to do
is in the last video, I looped through this array,
and the way I did that was by having a variable
i, we waited until it was, what do you call it
greater than the length of the list? And then once
it was, we simply broke out of that, that loop,
right? Okay. So an easier way to do this, is to
do something like this. So we're going to have
the same exact syntax, except in these brackets,
something is going to be different. Okay? What
I'm going to do if I want to loop through every
element in this list is I can do something like
this, I can say for element colon arr. Now what
this is actually going to do, I have to do this
sorry, string element, or I can't say string
because that's something we type into element
in our array. So what I'm doing now is I'm saying
that every time we loop through this loop, right,
what we're going to do is we're going to declare a
new variable called element, and it is going to be
equal to the next element in our array. So in this
case, when we first loop element is going to be
equal to one, and then elements going to be equal
to five. And that's going to be equal to seven,
and then three, and then four, and then five.
And this is a way easier way if I wanted to,
like print out the element, or look at certain
elements to do so rather than having to have
like a counter variable i and then index all of
the different elements, especially if we don't
know the length of the array, or we don't want
to do dot length, because this is automatically
going to go from start to end. Okay. Now, I'm
going to show you because, obviously, we need an
example to really understand this. But the first
example I typically like to do is just printing
out all these elements to show you that is indeed
working. So in this case, we'll say element,
okay. And we'll just print this to the screen and
see what we get. So in this case, you see, we get
157345, right, starting at the beginning going
to the end, the way this works with the colon is
again, we're just grabbing the elements in order,
and we're using those as a variable element. Now,
a lot of times when you want to do with this is
you want to be checking the element, but you also
want the index as well. So you want the element
and you want the index. Now we could use what
we used in the last video where we just have a
counter variable, and that way we have the index
and the element because we can do like arr of
one like all that, okay, I. But a way that people
typically do this is with like an outside counter
variable that you increment yourself. So I'll show
you how this works. So what we're gonna start
off by doing is just creating variables called
int count equals zero. And then within this loop,
we're going to increment count ourself. So now,
every time that we run the loop, we're adding
one to count. So that count is keeping track of
the index of the element. So if I print out the
element plus we'll do is I can't do that plus a
space plus our count, you can see that this is
keeping track of the index. So what's happening
here says one is that index 05 index one, and it
keeps track of all these different indexes for
us. And that's a really easy way to do that.
I just wanted to show it doesn't really make
sense for this example case, but I just wanted
to show you because there will be situations
where you want both the element and the index,
and it's easier to get the element just by doing
this with this colon. Okay. So again, when you're
doing a for each, this is what this is known as,
because it's going through for each element in
the array, we are doing something, okay. Alright,
so the next thing that I want to do is I want
to show you how we can populate an array using a
for loop. So right here, for example, we have a,
what he called a new string array that's empty,
right, like all these elements are null,
and we want to populate them. So the way
that we would go about doing this, and this is
a common example of what you want to do this,
while I'm showing you this is we create a variable
and say again, int i equals zero, we will say,
well, i is less than and then names dot length,
right? And then we'll do semi colon, and we'll
simply add one to it. So this is the exact same
thing as we done before. But I'm going to show you
how we can actually add the elements because it's
a really common use case. So what I'm going to do
here is I'm actually going to use the scanner to
get a new variable or to get like a name from the
user. So I'm just going to say scanner SC equals
new scanner and then we need system.in Okay,
and actually think I should probably not declare
this every loop but put it Up here, because we're
just going to use the scanner, right? So we'll
say string, input equals SC dot next line like
this. And this way, every time we run the loop,
we're going to get input from the user. And you
know what, let's also just print out here, system,
dot out, print ln and just tell the user we want,
I should let us do print not ln, we'll say, input
like that. So that way they know what to type in.
Okay, so input, we're getting input. And now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to add the
user's input into our array. So how can I do this?
Well, this is really easy, I can just do names, i
is equal to input, right? So we're just declaring
that whatever index we are in the loop right now,
so whatever value by well, that value in the list
or sorry, the list, I keep calling it lists, it's
an array I'm going to use to Python is going to be
equal to whatever we typed in. And then if we want
to print out the entire array, what we can do is
we'll use another for loop. So we'll just say for,
and then this time, it's going to be a for each
loop, right? So we'll say for an a Stanford name,
string, and, and names, okay, then we will simply
just do System dot out dot print ln, and we will
print every value of n. Okay, so let's two good
examples. Let's run this and just make sure
everything's working. So we run this input, I'm
just gonna type Hello. I guess I wanted names in
that, Tim, Bob. Joe, Bill. And then there we go.
So we ran that five times. And we get Hello, Tim,
Bob, Joe. And Bill. Awesome. There we go. So that
gives us all the values that we need. Okay. Okay,
so now what I want to show you guys is how we can
break out of the loop. So if we're in the loop,
and we're going through, and we're doing
operations, and we've not yet met the condition,
where are like, so the loop is gonna keep
going like is not greater than whatever value
or whatnot. Okay, then we want to break out of it.
How can we do that? So how can we just get out of
it in the middle of looping? Well, there is this
magical little keyword called break. And what this
does, is whenever this is encountered inside of a
loop, it simply breaks out of the loop. So in this
case, what would happen is, since I have break
at the end, we would do these first three lines,
then we just break. And this would only happen one
time, no matter what no matter what any of this
stuff said, this loop would only happen once. Now,
I'm going to show you just down here in this loop,
how we can break out based on like a certain
condition. So for example, say we encountered the
word end. Or what do you call it? The word Tim,
what am I saying? And I was just reading that,
if we encounter like the word Tim, while
we're reading through the list of names,
then we just want to break out like we don't want
to print any more names anymore, we just want to
break out. So the way that I can do this right now
I can say well, we're gonna we're gonna print Tim,
but we'll break after Tim Okay, so what I'm gonna
do, I'm gonna do an if statement, I'm gonna say if
and equals equals or not equals equals dot equals,
okay. And in this case, we'll just simply put Tim
in here, then what we're going to do is we're
going to break. And in this case, Now, whenever
we encounter Tim, we're simply breaking into the
loop. And that means we will not print the rest of
the names. So if I run this string, this console
up here, and we run and we say, Hello, let me say
name. And then we say, Tim, and I'll just show you
this Tim, and Tim. And I run this here, you see
we get Hello, name and Tim. And these other two
Tim's do not print. And again, that's because once
we hit m, and n is equal to 10, we simply break,
okay, and we get out of the loop. And that's like
a really easy way to just break out of the loop.
And this is going to work for a while loops that
we do in what do you call it the next video.
Now typically break is not something you want
to be using a lot like you only use this if you
really have to, it's better to just make these
conditions work the way they should, and have the
loop run, like as many times as it needs to run,
you know what I mean? So just try not to use this
too much. But I mean, there's nothing really wrong
with using it, people just are frowned upon it in
the programming world using the word break. Okay.
We're gonna be talking about while loops. Now,
while loops are very similar to for loops,
anything you do with the for loop, you can
indeed do with the while loop. That being said,
they do have different use cases in terms of
where they're most useful. But just remember,
anything you do with the for loop, you can do with
a while loop, anything you do with the while loop
you can do with the for loop, they're completely
interchangeable. And if you only had one of
them in programming, you'd still be able to do
everything. It just might be not as I don't know,
nice to code, that's the right word for it, or
elegant is probably the better word. So a while
loop is going to work when you typically don't
know how many times you want to loop through
something. So it's kind of like a question.
Like, you know, it's going to be based on this
condition. But you're not really sure like, if a
for loop is more like, you know, you're gonna do
it a set amount of times a while loop is it could
change based on the program based on user input,
okay, something like that. So what we're gonna do
here with this while loop is I'm just gonna set
one up, and then we'll just talk about exactly
what it does. So in this case, what I want my
while loop to do is I want it to just continually
keep asking the user for input until they give
me like a certain word or like one or two words.
Okay, so in this case, what I'm gonna do, I'm just
gonna say, let's see, maybe just get an answer
to be faster, say int, x equals SC dot, next int
like this. Okay? And what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna keep looping through until they type
the number 10. Okay, so all I can do this as you
just type the keyword Well, in here, and then in
these brackets is going to be your condition. Now,
this is why I focus so much about conditions in
the first few videos, because they go a lot with
if loops while loops for loops. So whenever while
this condition is true, then we're going to run
the loop. So in this case, I'm going to say, well,
x does not equal 10. Okay. Yeah, exactly. That's
true. So if they type in 10, then you will not
continue to do this. Otherwise, we will continue
to do this. So that means I'm also going to have
to get the INT in here, because every time that we
run this loop, we want to continue getting x. So
in this case, we already have X, fine, we just do
x. And what I'm gonna do is if they don't type in
10, I'm simply going to tell them like type in 10.
So we'll just say, dot print, ln, in this case,
I will just say, type 10 dot, dot, dot. And
now what we're also just going to print out,
because I like to do this, we'll just do system
dot out, dot print, ln, and in this case, we'll
say type a number. Cesar knows what we're looking
for. Okay. And that means we're also gonna have to
print this here. And it should just be print, not
print and print ln my apologies. Okay. So again,
the way this is gonna work is we're just
going to continually keep looping through
this until eventually the user types in
10. In that case, we will break it, okay,
and we will not do this anymore. So let's run this
type of number, let's type four. So it's type 10,
data, type a number, type five doesn't work, type
10. There we go. And we broke out of the loop,
and it no longer asked us for that number. Now,
these are actually really simple. It just wow,
this condition is true. Do everything that's
in here. And that's all you really have to know
about while loops. Now again, like we can what
I was saying we can do everything that with for
loops with while loops, because we can also count
and Wallops as well. So just like I did before,
I could do something like int count equals zero.
And then every time we run this loop, we could
just say count plus plus. And then maybe at the
end of our loop, we wanted to do like, tell them
how many times they messed up. Okay, what am
I saying print system dot out, dot print, ln.
And in this case, we'll just say you tried, tired,
you tried. And then plus couch. plus, times scan,
make sure we add a little space here. Alright, so
now if we run this, and we'll say like 123 and 10,
you tried three times until like, eventually, you
got it. Okay. So that's like a really simple way
to do stuff with while loops. Now, you guys
might notice that this code here like this,
these lines are repeated up here. So I have this
index and this type of number. So how can I do
this without repeating those lines? Because
I don't want to have to type like, what if I
wanted to ask a ton of different questions and
then do the wallet? Well, I don't want to have
the same section of code appearing multiple times.
So there's actually something called a do while
loop. So what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to erase all this. And I'm going to set up this
a do while loop. And it's pretty much what it says
we're going to do everything while this is true.
And you'll see how it works in just a second.
So I'm going to type the keyword do brackets,
and now everything in this brackets is what is
going to happen. Wow. The condition that I put
down here is true. So the condition here is going
to be the same. Well, x does not equal 10. We're
going to do everything in here. So now you can see
this is working fine. There's no issues. And what
I'm going to simply do is I'm going to take this,
these two lines here, I don't need that scanner.
So we're not going to redefine that every time.
And I'm going to paste them in here. And what
this is going to allow us to do now is x does not
equal zero. Create local, gosh, okay. Let's just
do this. int x and then x. Okay, perfect. There
we go. So sorry, that was just a quick issue.
But what this is going to allow us to do is we're
automatically going to do this once no matter what
this is going to happen once because we're going
to do this and at this point x is not equal to 10.
So we're automatically going to do this once which
means we don't have to have it up top and then
down below. So we do that. And then we check the
condition. If it's true, we'll do it again. Yeah.
And if it's not, then we will break. So we can
do this, we'll say type a number, let's do four,
let's do five, let's do negative 00. Number, okay,
and 10. And there we go, we break out of the loop,
and everything is working fine. And that
is pretty much it for while loops. Again,
if you wanted to set one up to look like a for
loop, then you'd literally just have to create a
variable in this case, say like index equals zero,
you can set up a while loop. So you say a while
and you say, x is less than or equal to 10. And
then in here, you just say x plus equals one,
or plus equals two, or whatever value you want to
add to it. And then you can just do what you would
do in the for loop underneath your increment.
Or you could put the increment, typically you
put it at the end. So at the end of the loop,
you're adding one and then you're checking, okay.
Now in this video, I'm going to be talking about
sets and lists. Now sets and lists are from
something known as the collection interface from
Java, I believe, that's what it's called someone
correct me if that's wrong, but I think that's
the name. And they are fairly complicated. Now,
I'm just going to talk about really the basics
of them, there's a lot more to do with sets
and lists. I know, I'm probably gonna get some
comments from some guy who says, Wow, you really
didn't talk about a lot of this, you didn't. But
I can't explain all of it to you guys right now.
Because it's very difficult to understand, if
you don't know a lot about data structures,
which in our case, we don't. So I'm just going to
talk about what a list is, what a set is quickly
in a very basic standard implementation of them.
Now, the reason I'm doing this is because whenever
you're programming stuff, like a lot of Java
tutorials you watch probably won't talk about
these, because they're really complicated.
But you're going to need them to do certain
things. So for example, with an array, what I
talked about before, how you could like, you
had to set the size of the array, like you had to
know how many elements you wanted, you don't need
to do that with a set or with a list. And that's
the main advantage of it. Because a lot of times,
we're gonna be adding things into per se a list or
set, and we don't know how many things we're gonna
be adding. So we can't define like an array of
that length, if that makes sense to us. So let's
actually just get started, we're gonna talk about
sets first, and then we'll move into lists. So I'm
just gonna create a set, and I'm just gonna type
it out and then kind of explain exactly what I'm
doing, I'm just going to call this set t equal
to new, new hash set, and integer. Okay, so this
already probably looks confusing. And if you're
typing this out with me, you're getting these red
lines. Now, what we should do to get rid of these
red lines is we just have to hover over them and
click Import set by like clicking on whatever it
says there. If you don't have you're not using
this Id just literally type import Java dot util
dot set. And for hash set, same thing, we're gonna
click on it and import it, just because this isn't
like built into main, the Java functionality.
Alright, so we have a set. Now what is a set?
How do we create it? Well set is a collection of
unordered elements that are unique, meaning that a
set cannot contain the same element twice, and it
doesn't know where that element exists. So you can
kind of think of a set as just like a big bubble,
and you kind of just throw things into it. And
it doesn't really know where they are, they just
knows that they exist there. Now you also have to
understand that can only be unique things. So for
example, I've created this integer set. And this
is the way that you do it. So you type the keyword
set. In these little like greater than sign
less than sign river, you want to call it tags,
if you're talking HTML type integer, and I have
the name T, and I'm setting that equal to new
hash set. Now you don't have to understand what a
hash set is just know that it's like the standard
implementation of a set. And then same thing, the
types are integer and then these brackets here.
Now inside of these brackets, if you had another
set you had created, like say a set created a set
called like W, I could put w in here. And assuming
it had any elements in it, this set would get all
of the elements from W and start with that and
then you could add things into it and whatnot.
Okay. So to add things to set, I'm just gonna
do this. We'll go through and see how it works.
You simply type dot add, so I'm going to say T
dot add. In this case, I'm going to add five.
And we'll just copy this and we'll add like a few
different numbers into our sets just because it's
seven, and what five again, and add nine. Okay?
Now what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna print
this set out to show you what it looks like. Now
remember, I said unordered collection of unique
elements. Okay, so let's print this out. And you
can see that we get five, seven and nine. And
notice that this odd right here actually didn't do
anything. And that's Because since we already have
a five in our set, when we try to add another five
to it, since it already exists, it doesn't care
and it just doesn't add it. Alright, now I'm gonna
add another element. In this case, let's add like
negative negative zero, negative eight, alright
as our element. And you can see that we don't
have any specific order. Now, see, when I printed
this, like I had added 579, and negative eight,
so you think that should be the order that we
get it or it should come in some sorted order
or something like that. That doesn't happen with a
hash set. Okay, standard hash set. And that's just
because again, we're just a bubble, we just know
that things exist, we don't care where they exist,
or how many times they exist, we just care if they
exist. Now to see if something exists in a set,
and this is typically something you want
to do like this is a main operation,
checking if something exists, that's why you use a
set, you can type T dot contains, or like your set
named contains, and then any element in here that
you want. So in this case, I can do like, if five
is contained in the set, and it's going to be able
to tell me that really fast. Now, I can't really
explain to you why sets are so fast. But just know
that whenever you're looking for something in a
set, you can do that very quickly, like very fast,
like in constant time, it doesn't matter how big
the set is, the set could be 2 million elements,
or it could be five elements, it will take you the
same amount of time to look if something exists
in the set. Okay, and same thing with adding and
removing things from the set that happens almost
instantly. As opposed to with arrays, the larger
the array gets, the longer it's going to take us
to look through and find certain elements, okay,
just, we have to understand that. So what I'm
gonna do is create a variable, I'm just gonna
call Boolean, x is equal to this. And what I'm
going to do is I'm simply just going to print
x. Now let's see if that is contained. And in
this case, yes, it is, five is contained. Again,
if I do something like zero, then obviously we
get false, it's not in there. To remove something,
we can type T dot remove, or set name dot remove,
and then whatever the element is that we want to
remove. So in this case, we want to remove like
nine from my set, I would do that. And then if I
print my set, so in this case, t, which get five,
seven, negative eight, because we removed nine,
those are kind of like the standard operations,
to I'm trying to think if there's any other ones,
okay, so there's one more, or there's a few more,
but I don't know which ones are important, you can
clear an entire set by just doing dot clear. So
just simply remove everything from it like that.
To see if a set is empty, you can do.is empty, and
this will literally just tell you if it's empty
or not, to get the length of the set, you can do
dot size, and this will tell you how many elements
so in this case, value, size, change this to an
int, and just print x here, then we get a size of
three. So like, again, if we had nothing in there,
the size would be zero, so is empty, and that are
kind of like similar in the sense that you can
just check by the size. Um, and yeah, so that's
a hash set. A hash set is like the standard set.
And that's the way that it works. We explained it
to you. Now they also have a tree set. And we also
have a linked hash set. Now whenever you use these
things, they're gonna pop up here, I'm not really
gonna talk about what these do too much. I'm just
gonna kind of show you the way a tree set works.
Now tree set is similar to set in the sense that
you can only have the or a hash set, sorry that
you can only have unique elements. But these are
actually ordered and they're ordered in a tree
data structure. You don't have to understand what
this means just know that it's like it shows
up ordered. what's what's our problem here,
just want to read this error. Tree set cannot be
resolved to a type. Interesting. Okay, Teresa,
well, let's just try this. That still worked.
Okay. So anyways, I don't know why I was showing
me there. But Teresa is going to actually
give us an order. So if I type T like this,
you can see that we actually have an order
for the set now. So negative eight, five,
and seven. Now like arrays, like we can't just
index the set. And we can't just say like t zero,
like that doesn't work doing that, like we were
able to do with the race. But when we print it
out, or when we look through the set, it maintains
this order in the katri functionality that I can't
really explain to you. Now linked hash sets are
this. So linked hash set again, we're gonna have
to import this up there. It's linked hash set. And
this is similar to a basic set it just faster on
certain operations. So I'm not I don't really
want to talk about them too much, because I
feel like I'm already confusing you guys, but
just understand if maybe you know a bit about
like operations and speed and time complexity.
They have a linked hash set, a regular hash set,
and a tree hash set or tree set. Whatever I typed,
okay? Alright, so that's enough for sets. Don't
worry if this is a bit confusing, like, we're,
we're not going to be using these too much,
I just want to show you cuz I feel like you
guys are going to need to do this for some of
your projects or whatnot if you're learning this
for a reason. Now, we also have lists now lists,
these are easier to understand, don't worry. But
there is again, two types of to create a list,
what we're going to do is we're going to type
array list, we're going to give it a type in this
case, I'm just gonna give my integer type. And
notice how I'm not typing int I'm typing integer,
just that's important that we need to use integer
here instead of int. Okay, so ArrayList integer,
I'm going to call this one Tega and equals
new array list. And we'll type integer,
and we'll put brackets and there we go. Now we're
gonna have to import this so important ArrayList
up there. And we now have an A list. And what
a list allows us to do is it's, you can almost
think of it as the exact same thing as an array,
except it's a bit slower. And it can change sizes,
so we can add things to it, we can remove things
from it. And if we get like the end of the array,
or the end of the list, sorry, we can add another
element into it, it doesn't matter. So we can have
like a dynamically sized array. These have pretty
much identical properties to the set. So to add
things, you can do t dot add. And you can add like
an element you want to add like one right? Okay,
that works fine. To remove things T dot remove.
Now to index things, because just like an array,
we can actually index things with the list
because this is going to care about the position,
it's not going to just care that it exists like
a set, what we can do is we can do t dot get,
and then we can give an index, right? So even it's
showing, it's always saying index right here. So
I do dot index zero, then that would give me one,
right because one is added in there. Now to like
put thing to put something or to set something on
a certain index where you do this is T dot set,
and you type the index and the element. So I want
to set index one per se to be equal to like five,
then that's where I would do it, index one is
five, okay, we print out t here just to show
you what it looks like. Okay, sorry, that's we
can't do that we have to do t, we have to add
something. So to set something like this, sorry,
you have to actually have something added at the
index. I forgot I didn't add that. So I'm just
gonna add to what I'm doing now essentially,
is what this set actually does is you have to
have something already existing at that index.
And this is going to change that index for you.
So this is to change an already existing index.
And before I was trying to set one, when we didn't
have that in so that was my mistake. But anyways,
there we go. So now that works. We've changed
to equal to five and twos up position one,
right. So that's the way that that works. I've got
a thing up here, I'm just going to read through a
few of these set. Yeah, okay, so that's the basic
ones. Again, we have dot size, so T dot size,
we can do t dot empty, or is empty. And this
is actually really useful when it's called sub
list. And what this allows us to do is get from
certain indexes. So T dot sub lists, let's see at
argument, yeah, so we just need an int. So this is
going to allow us to get within a certain range.
So say I add like these a bunch of times. Okay,
so we have six elements. Now, what, what I want to
do is I want to get from like index one to index
three, and I want to print that to the screen. So
let's just take this and put this here instead. So
let's get rid of TIG or the semicolon, and print
out and see what we get. So we get here now is
five and one because although our list actually
has what do you call it, like six elements in it
from here, we can just get the elements from 123,
not including three. So if I type like 124, then
you should see we get one more element in here,
we get five one and two, because that's from from
index one to index four, but not including index
four. That's what we're grabbing, we're getting
all those elements in the the sub lists like that.
Now, this is ArrayList. We also have linked list.
Again, this is another data structure that I can't
really explain to you just understand that it is
faster at certain operations than an ArrayList.
So for any of you to understand the difference
between this you have linked lists and ArrayList.
And you guys, I recommend you to play with
those and figure them out on yourself. Anyways,
we're coming up on about 15 minutes now almost.
And that's pretty much all I wanted to talk about
with sets and lists. Now I know this video
might have been a bit confusing. There's a
lot of stuff that I wasn't able to explain to you
guys. But just understand that if you're trying
to do something and you don't know how long you
want something to be like a list or an array.
You don't know how long you want it to be. It's
a different amount of time. If you don't know,
you would just use an ArrayList the way that I
showed that to you before, so ArrayList like that,
because then you can add things, you can get
things, you can set things. And you don't have
to worry about like having a designated length.
The reason you use a set is when you don't care
how many times something exists or where it
exists, you just care if it exists. And the
reason a set is better is because it's simpler.
And it's a lot faster to do operations on in
terms of like a computer efficiency standpoint,
that's when you would use a set. I'm going to
be talking about hash maps, or like Java maps. The
reason I say it like that is because there's a few
different implementations of maps, similar as to
how there's different implementations of lists,
and like ArrayList, and all that stuff. So
maps, if you're coming from Python, like me,
you can think of them as dictionaries. And I'm
only talking about three different types of maps.
So a hashmap, a tree map, and what was the last
one, I got it written down here, linked hash map,
sorry, just forgot about that one. So pretty much
a map is known as a key value pair in any other
languages, they're typically called dictionaries,
or hash tables, or hash maps or whatnot. Okay, so
to create a map, and I'm just gonna do this, and
then we'll talk about exactly what it does, we're
just gonna create a map M is going to equal to new
hash map like this, okay. And this is your simple
syntax, now to we have to import this. So I'm just
gonna import Java dot util. So just by clicking on
it, we have to import map as well. So we'll import
the map there. So you see those. It's all coming
up now for us. Okay, so now that we have that, I
want to talk about exactly what a map is. Now map,
like I said, is a key value pair, meaning that
it's similar to like a list and an array in the
sun, so you can index things. But instead of
indexing them by numbers, you index them by
keys. Now keys can be anything that you want. A
key could be a string, a key could be an array,
actually, I'm not sure if it could be an array,
but it could be a string, it can be a number,
it can be a char, it can be a float, what like
pretty much whatever you want can be the key.
And that key links us to a value. So the easiest
way to kind of demonstrate this is just to do it,
and then to talk about what's really happening. So
to put a new value into a hashmap, or into a map,
what you do is you have to specify a key, and
a value. So you type whatever the name of your
map is, in this case, m dot put, and then you
need to put a key in a value. So in this case,
for my key, I'm going to type Tim, and it is going
to lead to the value five, so I type Tim, and then
the value is five. So I put that in there. And
now I'll just show you what it looks like if we
print this out to the screen. Because I think it
will give us a decent representation system. What
am I saying System dot out dot print ln Sorry,
guys more tired today. And we'll print em and
see what we get. So in this case, you can see we
see this a curly braces as Tim is equal to five,
meaning that if we're to index Tim, we get the
value five. Now, how do we do that? So how do we
actually get a value based on a key, the way
we can do this is if you put square brackets
next to your map, are actually you can't do like
this Python, we have to m dot and then get Sorry,
I'm still used to the Python syntax here, guys,
we type m dot get Okay. And then we put the key
in here. So in this case, I'm going to put Tim as
my key. And what you should already be predicting
what we're going to get out to the screen. In this
case, we get the value five and not as because
the key Tim leads us to the value five. Now to
put another thing into our map, we can do this,
right. So we do Tim we could do like Joe, and Joe
doesn't have to point to a number, it could point
to another string. And that string could be like,
I don't know x, okay. And we can just do whatever
we want. Like we can have the the key one and or
the key 11 and the key 11 points and 999. Okay,
and now if I just print em out, you'll see that we
don't get any issues. And that this works fine, we
get Joe equals x Tim equals 511 equals 999. Okay,
now, this is an extremely fast data set, meaning
or don't type, whatever you want to call it,
meaning that everything from adding to removing
to overriding to getting happens in constant time.
Now again, like I talked about in my stats video,
you don't really have to understand what that
means. But if you do, that's great. And just
know that this does happen in constant time. Now
I'm going to show a, I still show the tree map
and the what was the other map talked about linked
hash map first, and then we can kind of talk about
the differences between them. So with a hash map,
as opposed to the other type of maps, I'm going to
show you this one does not retain an order. So all
of these maps can only contain unique elements or
unique keys meaning that if I try to add another
key, so I try to add 11 nine Try to add this to be
998. Instead of adding another key that's equal to
11. We're simply overriding this already existing
key that is 11. So in this case, you can see that
we override it and we get 998. You cannot have to
have the same keys existing in the map. But you
can have to have the same values if you'd like to.
Okay, so sorry, that kind of got me off track.
But that was important to understand. So this
hashmap does not guarantee the order in which
we add things in. So you can see that I added
Tim, and then I added Joe, and then I added 11.
And it showed me Joe, Tim and 11. Now this is not
any kind of sorted order, because how do we sort
numbers and strings and all that stuff together?
It's not in the order that we added it in. So what
order is it in? Well, it is in no order. And that
is why this hashmap is extremely fast, because
it does not keep track of the order of elements
when they go in. So just know that if you're
trying to like look through the map, because
you can iterate through maps, and I'm going to
show you that in a second. It doesn't keep it in
the correct order. Okay. Now, the next map that
we're gonna talk about is the tree map. Okay,
now this tree map is what we're gonna have to
import it, of course, is similar to the tree list,
or the tree set, or whatever one I showed you in
the earlier video. In that when we add things in,
it's actually going to keep it in a sorted order.
So if I run this, I'm actually curious to see what
kind of sort we're going to get. Okay, so we
don't get anything. So that's, that's actually
a good area to run into. Whenever we're using a
tree map, the types that we add to the map have
to be the same, meaning that the keys have to be
the same datatype. At least I'm pretty sure. So
I'm gonna just gonna see if I remove this, if this
is going to work for us. Yes, so in that case,
we do get in a sorted order, we get Joe and then
we get Tim, because obviously j is before T. And
that's where it's going to sort strings. So if I
try to put like an A value in here, so it's Yeah,
it's even true on a key value, I'll literally
just put like a is equal to b. And I guess we
can't set equal we have a comma. What's our air
semi colon, always forgetting those are? Okay,
so we'll run this. There we go. So you see, we get
a first because obviously a well it's first letter
in the alphabet. So that's going to show up for
Joe. And for Tim. So that sorts the order for us.
And that means that the data types for the keys
that we pass in have to be the same. So we can use
numbers, we can use strings using whatever data
type you want, there's got to be completely the
same for that map. Now, the other type is a linked
hash map. And what this does, is it's similar to a
list in that it keeps the same order that you add
things into it. So in this case, if I print out m,
you can see we get Tim Joe and then a and that's
because it's actually going to maintain the order
in which we added elements. So it's gonna say,
Tim, that was first element. So that's gonna
be the first thing that we show. And then Joe,
that's gonna be the first thing and then a nursery
second, and then a, this is gonna be the third
thing, because that's the order in which we added
them in. And those are the only main differences
other than, like, the speed of which these things
run out, that you have to kind of understand
right now, okay, and typically, whenever you do
anything, you're just gonna be using a hashmap,
you don't really need, like a linked hash map,
or a tree hash map, or tree map, whatever it's
called for any of the stuff that we're gonna
be doing right now. So what I'm going to do now,
is I'm just gonna show you a few methods, how we
can kind of clear the maps, how we can like remove
elements, and some useful things you might want to
do. So what we can do to get all the key values
or to get like a certain key value, we can say,
Actually, I'll just show this one first. Well
we can actually do is is just cool things that
are going to be really useful to you. And dot
contains value. So this is let's see, this method
contains values not available for type map. Hmm,
interesting. Match contains value object. Yeah,
so we just have to put something there. Okay.
So m dot contains value. And then in here,
we're just going to put like any value on so in
this case, B. So what this is going to do is it
is actually going to check for us if this value
exists in the map. And remember, the values are
all these these second elements here. And they
are linked up or like attached to the key. So
it's going to tell us if b exists. Now we can do
the same thing with keys and the keys are more
useful. And I'll show you why in a second contains
key and in this case, for the key I could put like
contains the key five, right and that will give us
a true or false value similar to what we're doing
with sets and lists in the last video. Okay.
Now the reason keys are more useful is because
if I try to do something like m dot get, and I
put the key, let's say five, well the key five
does not exist, the value five exists, but the
key five does not exist. So watch what happens
when I run the program. m dot get five actually
let's just see what this is printing out to us.
Because I'm curious if this is gonna crash. Let's
Let's see here. I'm not getting five No, yeah,
so this isn't gonna actually crash for us. If we
try to get Ah, what do you call it a key that does
not exist in the map, but it's going to return us
a no value because this key does not exist in the
map. That's actually interesting. I didn't know
that in Python, if you try to get a key from map
or from a dictionary, and it doesn't exist, you
actually get an error. So that's interesting to
know. Anyways, I guess another method I could
show is, let's see here, dot values. So what
this is going to do is it actually just prints out
all of the values in the map. So if I copy this,
and I simply print it down here, we get m dot
values. And in this case, it'll just give me x,
b, and five, which are all these and you can
see, it gives me that in no particular order,
it's important to remember, values, let's see
if there's any other ones we can use. We can use
clear so I just got a text document beside me cuz
I always forget all these to show you, I always
forget which ones. So Am I clear? Obviously,
this is just going to remove everything from the,
what do you call it the map. So we get an empty
map. And I believe the last one is, is empty. And
this one like that is simply just going to tell us
if the map is empty. Or if it's not up to you know
how much time we had 10 minutes. So I actually I
am not going to show you an example of using these
maps. But if you want to think about this, and
maybe try programming this yourself using the maps
that I just showed you be good exercise. And that
is given a string, or like an array of characters,
count all of those characters into a map. So
have a key that's equal to, let's say the letter,
and then the value for that key is equal to the
how many times that letter occurs, or how many
times that character occurs, and try to do that
yourself. And if you're able to accomplish that,
well, then you're definitely learning and you're
understanding the stuff that I'm explaining.
What I'm going to be doing is showing you some
common problems you're going to want to solve
and how you can do that with the information
I've showed you so far. So kind of bringing
everything in now, mixing it all together, and
using all the things. And this is a really good
way to kind of like apply all the knowledge that
we've just learned into solving like a few common
computer problems. Because a lot of the time
you guys learn how to do all this stuff, but
you don't know how to kind of mix it all together.
And that's what I'm trying to do in this video. So
I'm also going to be showing you some like useful
methods and some things that I may have forgotten
to talk about in previous videos. So yeah, that's
what this video is going to be about. So in the
last video, I mentioned that a good exercise to
do would be if you have like, I don't know a word,
and you want to count or like a sentence or a
string, you want to count all the letters and
store them in like a hashmap and have the letter
as the key and the value being how many times they
appear. So I figured for any of you guys that
were brave enough to attempt that on yourself,
I would show you a solution here quickly to doing
that. And for any of us who didn't see that,
make sure you pay attention, because this is
really useful, it's going to help you also to
understand kind of how maps work and how you can
use them. So what I'm going to do first of all,
is I'm just going to create a string, let's
call str is equal to and I'll say, Hello,
my name is Tim. And I am Cool. All right,
very creative string name anyways. So we're
going to do that just because we're going to
count all the letters in the string. Now the
human way to count this would be to go through
and literally read like each letter and be like,
okay, so I have an L how many times the L appear.
But I will show you how we do this with maps and
for loops, like very efficiently in computing.
So what I'm going to do is create a for loop,
what we're going to do is we're going to loop
through the string. And the way that we can do
this is because if I try to do like for char
our like x because it's going to be character,
right. And in str you see we get this red line,
it says we can't iterate over a string. So the way
that we can do this is actually a cool method and
a useful method. And it is going to convert the
string into a character array for us. And the way
that we can do that is by doing angas dot.to char
array. And this is if I literally just print this
out for you, if you want to see what it looks like
System dot out dot print ln is simply just going
to put every character so including the spaces
into a character array for us. So let's just run
this. And you can see it just is literally just
printing this entire thing, but it's actually
in an array, and this is going to allow us to
loop through it. So you'll see in a second. Okay,
so what I'm going to do now is every character,
I'm going to see if that key already exists in
the map. If it does, I'm going to get the value
because that value is gonna be how many times it
exists. So in this case, say I'm looking for like
m it already exists in the map, I'm just gonna
add one to it and then overwrite that key with
a new value. And you'll see what I mean here in
a second. So we're gonna say if m dot contains
Key of x, then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to say, old, we'll say int old equals m dot get,
and then the key is going to be x. And then what
we're going to do is, what's the issue here,
cast int, if I need this, forgetting all my
brackets, int old equals m dot get x, and x
should be interesting one second, saying I have to
cast this to an integer. Okay, let's just do this,
I don't think we actually need to do this, but
let's just cast it to an int. All right, anyways,
and then we'll say, dot quotes. And for the key
is going to be x two, that's going to be the
character. And we're gonna say old plus one. Now,
what this should do for us is just increment the,
the amount, so that's going to go up by one
now otherwise, so if that key does not exist,
what we're going to do is we're going to put
into our map, a new key, and the keys value
is going to be one because we just found the
first occurrence of that letter, and the key
is going to be x standing for the letter. And
that should work. Now after we do that, I want
to see the counts of all these letters. So to do
that, it's really help I spelt system correctly,
we're going to print the line, and we're just
going to print them. Okay, so quickly, I know
this fast, and you might not really understand
exactly what's going on. But we're just looping
through every letter in this string, we're going
to check, the first check is going to see if the
map contains that letter already. So as a key,
if it does not, what we're gonna do is we're
simply going to add in a key, and it's going to be
equal to that letter, and it's gonna have a value
of one. Because we just found it occurs one time,
we already know that. Now, if for some reason, or
if that key does exist, what we're going to do is
we're going to get that previous count. And then
we're going to add one to that previous count and
override the key. So like, if the count is four,
it goes up to five. Pretty straightforward. So
if I run this, you can see we get a space, well,
there's eight spaces, we get a, there's three AC,
there's one D, there's one, and it goes through
an account all of the different letters for
us. And if we wanted to confirm those correct,
we could go through and count them like
that. And just by looking at it here,
it does look as though that is correct. So yeah,
that's a really common way to use a map. Um, yeah,
it's really useful. And there's a lot of cases in
which you want to do something like that. Okay,
so the next thing I want to show you guys is
something I forgot to do in the last video. And
this is really just gonna take like 10 seconds.
But pretty much to remove an element from a map,
you probably already guessed, but it's literally
just m dot remove, and then you just type the key.
So I just felt like I had to say this, because
I watched back my other video, and I realized I
forgot to say it. So to remove an element, you
do m dot remove, and just put the key. So if I
want to remove like all the spaces, which actually
wouldn't be a bad idea to remove from our counts,
then if I do that. Interesting why it's not
letting me remove that. Let's try that maybe, oh,
it's because it's not because of character. My bad
Sorry, guys, I've been doing string a character
space is different. Yeah, so that it actually
removes the character, the space from our program,
or from our map, whatever. Okay. Now, the next
thing I want to show actually is sorting. So
sorting is something you typically want to do on
arrays. So I'm actually going to remove all this,
and I'm going to create a new array, an
integer array. And I say int x equals,
with cases do like three, and let's do a
bunch of different values and see if we
can get this to sort for us. Let's do negative
99. semicolon there for us. And to sort this is
actually really easy, all we have to do is just
type arrays, dot sorts. And then what it takes,
it takes two arguments. Now the first argument is
obviously going to be our array. So in this case,
x, and then the other two arguments are
actually optional. And what these do sources,
three arguments not to what these arguments do is
from a certain index, so if we want to sort just,
let's say, like this part of the list that's
highlighted, we can actually do that. And the
way that we would do that is we would type one
because we're gonna start at one. And then if
we were going to 71234567. Funny enough, we will
actually type seven. Now I know this is index six,
but the thing is, it's going to work up but not
including to that index. So if we type seven, it's
going to that seven, but it's only going to sort
up to like the actual number seven. Okay? And what
this does, and I believe is actually just changes
the list, we don't need to say like x equals
Arrays dot sort, we just say Arrays dot sort. And
then what we can do is we can do system dot out,
dot print ln, and we can print x. And let's see if
it did end up sorting that section of the list for
us. Okay, so we actually, man of course, we can't
do that. We're gonna have to set up a basic for
loop to print these out just because when we try
to print arrays, I forgot we get that little loop,
or we get that message because that's the memory
address. But anyways, let's say for int, i and x,
and then we'll simply just print out I, it's got
to make it complicated for us, doesn't it? And
instead of printing, ln, we're just gonna print.
And we'll just add a comma here just to make it
separated. Okay, so let's run that. So there we
go. So it actually did sort this middle section
of the list for us, right? So we got 1234567, you
see eight and zero, were not touched and negative
99 was not touched. Now, if you want to sort the
entire thing, and you don't want to worry about
these indexes, you can just put x, in this case,
if we do this, we're going to get an 899, zero
all the way up to eight. And yeah, so you could
sort like from three to five, or three to six,
or whatever, okay. And you can see, it's only
going to sort like a few of the elements in the
list for us, or in the array for us. So that's a
really useful way to sort things at quite quickly,
actually, in quite easily using just Arrays
dot sort. And remember, you don't have to do
like x equals Arrays dot sort. Because what it's
actually going to do is just sort in place all the
elements of x and swap them around, rather than
creating like a new version of x that is sorted.
Where you're going to be introducing object
oriented programming, and talking about what
objects are and getting a little bit into
classes and methods. So I think the first
thing to really talk about is what is an object.
So an object essentially is just an instance of a
certain data type. So we know we have data
types, like int strings, bool, scanners,
like all kinds of different things that we can
use, like ArrayList, hash table, hash, list,
whatever, or hash map all that stuff, okay. And
those are all known as data types, right? We're
classes if you want to say that. So whenever we
create an instance, by doing something like this,
like scanner, SC equals new scanner, essentially,
what we're doing is pointing this variable SC
to a scanner object, okay. And whenever we create
any kind of variables, like just type like int
x equals five, we're essentially saying x
is equal to an int object of value five,
okay? These objects are what allow us to have
different properties for different data types.
So you know how we can add integers together, or
how we can do like, dot parse int, on on strings,
and we can have like a bunch of different methods
and stuff. Those are all specific to the type of
object that we're using. So, for example, we
can see here I have the scanner object, right,
so SC is equal to a new scanner object that's
taking system.in as an argument, okay. So we can
only use this dot next method on SC because it is
a scanner type. If I try to do X dot x, and I do
a little semi colon here, you can see that we're
getting can't invoke next method on primitive type
int, because well, that method doesn't exist for
int, okay. And that's like a really basic way to
kind of understand what objects are essentially,
whenever we're creating a new variable. So like,
even just doing like string like, str equals,
hello, what we're doing is we're saying, well,
str is actually equal to a string object with
the value alone. And because of, or based on
the different types of objects, we have different
properties, different attributes, things we can do
with the methods we can call in, that's just kind
of important to understand, you'll see more how we
create like objects and whatnot, that are specific
to like classes that we're going to make in later
videos, okay, so it'll all start to come together.
But just now kind of know that what I'm calling
things objects, essentially, that's like you have
a variable of a certain type, and it's equal to
something, you're creating an object of that
type. Okay, that's all we can have to understand
for now. So now let's talk about methods. So
some of you may already understand what methods
are because I think I went through a very brief
like explanation of them in previous videos. But
essentially, methods are anything that you call on
an object or on an instance of an object. So just
to clarify, when instances when we're creating
a variable like this of a new scanner object,
we can say that we're creating FC is now an object
like a scanner object, or we can say, se is a new
instance of scanner of like the type of scanner,
and those kind of are interchangeable. So if I say
instance, instead of object, they're very similar.
Okay, so just bear with me on that. So anyways,
when we call this dot next method, we call it
on the like, variable, right? So that's, that's
pointing to our scanner object. So our scanner
object allows us to use this method. Again, I
showed you before, if I tried to call that on, for
example, the variable x that was like an integer,
that doesn't work because that object doesn't
have that method associated with it. So a method
is anything really that's just like a dot, and
then whatever the method name is, and typically
brackets, for example, if we had like, an array
like so we have or let's do actually strings are
just another string probably should have deleted
all these. But that's okay. We'll say string H
equals Hello. And I can do something like H dot
length. And this is a method that simply returns
to us the length of the string. And again, this
works on our object, which is a string, but it's
not going to work on our SC, because well, what
is the length of a scanner. So if I type that, you
can see that we're getting this red line here. And
that's obviously not giving us anything, because
this length method is not defined for a scanner
type. So that's kind of a bit about like how we
call methods. And you guys have already seen a lot
of different examples of methods that we can use
on different objects and different data types.
Okay. And same thing when I say like data types
and objects, data types are kind of like what the
object is created off of. And you'll see that more
in in future videos. Just want to clarify in
case anyone's kind of confused, okay, so how
can we create our own methods? Well, currently,
since we don't really know anything about classes,
we're going to be creating methods inside of this
main class. Okay, now, this main class is special,
because it is it contains this method. And
remember, I was telling you guys at the beginning,
this method automatically runs whenever we run the
program. Well, that's different than other methods
we're going to have in classes we create in future
videos. So it's a bit hard to explain this method
per se. But this is a method because a method is
typically anything that sits inside of a class and
the class is what's going to define like our data
types. So scanner. In Java, we can't see it right
now, there's actually somewhere that says public
class scanner, and inside of that scanner class.
So if you do like brackets like this, it has a ton
of different methods that are different attributes
that we can use by calling them from within this
function. Okay. So if we want to create our own
method within this main class, what we can do,
and this is just the default way that we're
going to do for now, I'm going to show you why we
use certain keywords and stuff in future videos,
but it's a bit advanced right now. We're something
in type, public static, okay. And then whatever
return type we want, which we'll talk about in
a second. So let's get going to void the name
of our method. So in this case, I'm gonna say
like, Tim, okay. We have a public static void,
Tim has your parameters, again, talk about that
in a second. And then it's going to do something
in here. In this case, I'm just gonna say system,
dot out, dot print, ln, and we'll just say, when
you call up, it just says Tim, like that. Okay. So
what have essentially done here is create a static
method that we can call from anywhere within this
class, okay, and actually outside of the class as
well. So what we need to do to call this method
from inside this class is we can literally just
type the method name since case by type Tim. And I
put a semicolon like that, and we run the program,
you see that we get is it running? one second
here, sorry. Okay, so I figured out why it
wasn't working, because we have this SC dot next
coming in here. So I'm just going to comment that
out for right now. And we will run this one
more time. And you can see that we get Tim to
the screen. Now I know, I didn't really explain
what this is or how this worked. But essentially,
what I've done here is I've created kind of like a
function, okay. And it's known as a method. But in
other programming languages, you might see this
as a function. And this void keyword. What this
means here is it returns nothing, okay, because
in functions, we can actually return values,
which I'm going to show or sorry, functions
methods, we can return values, which I'm going
to show you in just a second. So this stands
for, we are going to not return anything,
we're just going to do something in here. So in
this case, we're just printing something to the
screen. All right, now we have Tim. And this is
the name of our method. And that's what we call
here to trigger this to run, right. So if I wanted
to pass some information to Tim, so say I wanted
to print whatever string I passed to Tim, well,
what I would do in here is I would type string,
and then let's just say str like that. And now
this means that whenever we call this Tim method,
we have to actually pass it one piece of
information, and that piece of information has to
be a string. Okay, so I'm going to show you right
here. So I type str, I put Tim and I put Tim in
here like this, okay, and we run the program. Now
we see we're printing out Tim, if I change this,
like with a bunch of M's can see if we run this
we're getting Tim. Now the way that this works, is
this is called a parameter. So str is a parameter
of type string. And that means that whenever we
call this function, we have to type in arguments
and what arguments are is what the parameter is
going to be when we get to the method. So anything
that goes in here in the call statement, which is
what this is known as where we're like triggering
the method to run is known as an argument. Okay,
so Tim is an argument. When we call this what's
happening is we're passing Tim as str so now it's
saying like str equals Tim like the other
whatever the string is okay. And then we're
simply going to print to the screen. Whatever
it is that we were passed. So in this case, 10,
right? Now we can actually do multiple parameters
as well. So if I wanted to do another parameter,
I wanted to pass two pieces of information every
time we call this function, I would say maybe int
and X, okay? And now it means that I have to pass
not only a string, but I have to pass an int. So
that means we have to type an integer in here.
In this case, I'm gonna do four, what I'm going
to do now we're going to say four. And we'll say
int i. And we'll say i is less than x. And we'll
say i plus plus, we're just going to print this
that many times. Okay, so let's see here. Boom,
okay, so System dot out dot print line, what's
more, we get in here, initialize variable,
got to do that, sorry. Okay, so now we pass an
int, and we pass a string. And what we're going
to do is simply print this as many times as like
the input that we typed in, okay. So you can see
that we now we get Tim four times to the screen.
And that's how that works. So we have arguments
in here, the two arguments are Tim and four. And
then we have our parameters, which are STR and
x. And when we pass our information in str gets
equal to Tim, and x gets equal to four. Okay,
and then in here, we can now use those values by
referencing STR and X, like I've done. So. Okay,
so I hope that makes sense. Now, in terms of this
public static, I'm going to talk about this in the
next video. For right now, all this means is that
you can call this not on an instance of the class,
which is kind of what we're doing here, when we're
just calling Tim, okay, because we don't have any
object that's like a class main, which you'll
see in the next video. Okay. So that's kind of
how we can create our own methods. Again, we can
create methods that return things. So that's what
I wanted to talk about now. So all I'm going
to do is going to create another method. And
I'm going to say this is public static. And in
this case, I want to return an integer value to
whoever's calling this Okay, or wherever this
is being called. So I'm going to type int,
because this is what I'm going to return and
the function is going to give back to us and
the method is going to give back to us. And I'm
going to say add two as the name. And we're simply
going to take an integer x as our one parameter
here, see what the issue is here. Method must
return Yeah, okay. So you can see, it's already
giving us a red line saying that we have to return
a value in this method, because we typed in the
fact that we were going to turn it okay. So what
I'm going to do here is I'm simply going to return
x plus two. And what this is doing now, semicolon
is it's just taking a value x, and it's adding to
it and it's returning the value to our program,
wherever we call it. So let's just do something
up here, and show you how this is working. So
I'm going to say, system, dot out, dot print, ln,
and here, I'm simply going to type add two, and
then give it a number, in this case, six. Now, you
can probably guess what this is going to give us.
But essentially, what's happening here is we're
calling add two, we're giving it the value six, so
our argument is six, it's coming in here, and the
parameter x is now set equal to six, we're going
to return so back to wherever we call this x plus
two, in this case, eight. So we get eight here as
a value, and we go, and we bring it up here. And
now this little line is equal to eight. So we're
going to print eight to the screen. And you can
see that we get eight as a value like that. Now,
obviously, in methods like this, you're probably
gonna do some more advanced things. And just
adding to that shows you how we can return values.
And I'll do one last example of returning maybe
like a string value. So public static string,
okay, and we'll just say, str as their name,
because I don't really know what to do. And
we'll take a string x, okay. And then in here,
we have to return a string value. So what we could
do is we could return x plus and an exclamation
point. But I think I need to put that in double
quotation marks, like that. So what we're doing
now is we're adding an exclamation point to
the end of our string, and we're returning
that. So if I call str here. Okay, so we'll I
don't know why keeps doing with my brackets,
we'll do str. And then inside our brackets, we'll
give it high, it should return to as high with
an exclamation point. And indeed it does. And
yeah, that's kind of how methods work basically
going to be going over classes when we talk
about creating classes, creating some methods,
constructor methods, all that fun stuff, creating
instances and objects. And yeah, so this is going
to be kind of an advanced video. Don't if you've
been following along so far, you'll definitely be
able to follow along with it. But just know that
now we're kind of getting into some harder aspects
of Java. So if you guys don't understand this,
please don't hesitate to join my Discord server,
ask me some questions, leave a comment down below.
Because this is absolutely fundamental. And you
have to understand this before you can really
start doing any serious programming. And that goes
for kind of all languages, but Java, especially
since it is an object oriented language, we need
to understand classes and how to create classes.
So without further ado, let's get started. So
so far, we've been working in this class. Hold me
now this is not really a true class. Because this
class, all it's doing for us, is just running
some code right away when we run the program.
And that's what we have this public static void
main function that automatically triggers whenever
we click this little green Run button. Okay, so
what I'm going to do now, and you can see that I
have some methods that I've added in here that we
just kind of use within here earlier. Okay. What
I'm going to do now is I'm going to create my
own class, from scratch from scratch, and we're
going to start coding. So to do this, we're going
to go to whatever our packages. So in this case,
tutorial, one for me, and I'm going to go new and
class. And I just did that by right clicking. And
now I'm going to give my class a name. Now, for
this example, I'm going to create a dog class.
And yeah, you guys can create whatever you want.
But I would recommend you follow along with me,
since you guys are most likely new to classes.
Okay, so now we have this thing, and it says
public class dog. And you can see we open up in
a new file. So whenever we create a new class
in Java, we have to actually create a new file
for that. Now, that's actually good, because it
makes it really easy to navigate between different
classes. Whereas in something like Python, you can
just have all your classes in one file. Okay, so
what we're going to do now, is we have this public
class dog. So what does this What does this mean?
Like what is a class or class is pretty much a
data type. And whenever we create an instance of a
class, like an object of a certain type, all we're
doing is we're just using all the information
within the class to like create an object. So
you can almost think of it as like a blueprint
for an object. Now, what problems do classes
fall for us? Like, why are they useful? So I'm
going to introduce combos a very simple problem,
right? So I want to create five dogs, okay, I want
to have five dogs, I want each dog to have a name,
I want each dog to have an age. And I want to,
at some point, be able to like call something and
print out each dog's name and age and like a nice
form. Okay. Now, we could do that we know how to
do that. If we went back into main here, what we
could do in this little, what do you call method
here is we could just type a bunch of answer you
say it's like dog one. And this is equal to four,
and that's dog one's age, we say int dog two,
and that's equal to five. Or we could go on and
create 10 variables, five for the age and five
for the names, right? And then we could go and
we could print out each one each time. But
that is incredibly inefficient. And what if
I wanted to have like 10,000 dogs? Well, what
would what would I do, then? Well, we could use
like lists to create or lists or raised to create
names and ages. But that's just not efficient,
it doesn't look as good in our actual coding. So
what we're gonna do is we're gonna use a class,
and you'll see how we can kind of accomplish this
problem. So within classes, we have methods and we
have attributes, okay? Now attributes are kind of
like variables that hold information for us. So in
this case, we want to have two attributes in our
dog class. And these are going to be the name and
the age to create our attributes. And so the first
thing we typically do when we create a class is
right at the top of our class, we're going to type
keyword privates. And then we're going to give a
data types. In this case, we can say string, and
then the name of our attributes, in this case,
name, okay, and this all we have to do, we're
just declaring that at some point in time,
we're going to have the attribute name, and
it's going to be storing information later
on in our program. Okay, we can also do private
int. And in this case, we'll do age. And this
is going to obviously represent the dog's age.
Now, if you want to have some other attributes,
we would, again, type private. And we could keep
going and type a bunch of attributes. Now, what
is this private keyword? And why do we have public
up here and private here? Well, what this private
keyword does is it ensures that this name and
this age are only accessible within this class,
meaning that if I tried to do something over
here, and I wanted to use this age and this name
from this class, I wouldn't be allowed to do that.
And the program would say, No, this is a private
attribute, you can't access that. Why do we do
that? Well, you'd find out in larger programs,
but we can also create public attributes as well
that are accessible to the other classes. Okay. So
if I wanted my things to be public, I could put
public for now whenever we're using attributes,
we're going to use private, and it's best practice
to use more private things, okay. And same goes
for methods, which you'll see in a minute. Okay.
So now we need to create something called a
constructor method. Now this, you typically
only create one of these, although you can
create multiple, what this is going to do is it is
going to run automatically whenever we call this
dog class. And the way we create this constructor,
and we typically need one of these when we have a
class is we're going to do public. And we're just
going to type the name of our class once again,
so excuse me as a public dog, like this, okay.
And you can see that now we're getting no errors,
everything's fine. And in here, we're going to
type the parameters or the information that we
need to be passed in whenever we're creating a
dog object. Now, in some instances, you may have
nothing in here, when you create a dog object, all
you need to do is just say you're creating a dog
object. You don't need to give any information and
that's fine. But in our case, we want to be able
to create an age and a name with our dogs. So what
I need to do here As I need to type string name,
and int, age, okay, just meaning that whenever we
create a dog object, we need to give it a name,
and we need to give it an age. Now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to set these values. So these
attributes equal to whatever we pass in. Okay? So
what I'm gonna do is I'm actually just gonna use a
keyword and it's, the keyword is this, it's kind
of hard. If you weren't watching, you think I'm
just like saying this is a keyword and pointing
something, but this like actually typed out. And
then I'm doing this dot name is going to be equal
to name. And this dot age is going to be equal to
age. So what is this, this this keyword actually
doing? Well, it is referencing the attributes of
the class, okay? So when we type this, it is going
to be looking up here to find all of our like
private attributes. And in this case, we have an
age and we have a name, alright. And that's how we
reference things that are a part of the specific
instance, we have this name and this dot age,
okay, and I'm going to explain more and more
of this as we keep going. It's hard to do it
in like small steps. Okay. So now that I have this
constructor method created, we can go on to create
one more method, and then we can actually start
using this class really simply Okay, so what I'm
going to do now is I'm going to create another
method, in this case, I'm going to type a public,
I'm not going to return anything, so I'm going
to use void, okay? And the name is going to be
speak. And what this is going to do is it is
simply going to say something or prints me up
to the screen. So I'm gonna say system, dot out,
dot print ln, why did that? Okay, print ln, and
all we're gonna do is we're gonna say I am, and I
want to say that the dog's name. So in this case,
we'll say this dot name, okay? And we'll say plus,
and I am, you know, plus, we'll say, this dot age,
plus years old, okay? So suddenly gonna say like
I am, whatever the name is, and I am, however many
years old, not great grammar, but that's fine. So
now, how do we actually create a instance of this?
Or how do we use this class? Well, from our main
class here, which we should still have open, and
you know, we can delete all these, we don't need
all that. So we'll get rid of all this stuff here,
we can actually create a object and to do that of
type dog, what we're sending individual type dog,
and we're gonna give it a name. In this case,
we're gonna say Tim, is equal to new dog. Okay.
And then remember that we have to give dog some
parameters, right? So or arguments because we
have the name, and we have the age. So what we
need to do is we need to give it a name and an
age. In this case, we can type 10. And I'm going
to type four. And now you can see no red line,
we're looking good. So our dog's name
is Tim, and it's age as for. Okay,
so that's great. Let's run the program, make
sure this is working. Everything's fine. Now,
what I want to do is I want to use that
speaker. So how can I use that? Well, what
I'm going to do is I'm going to type Tim, which
is the name of my dog or like the variable for it,
dot speak like this, okay, semicolon. And let's
see what happens. We get I am Tim. And, excuse me,
I am four years old. So the way that this worked,
right, is we created a instance of the dog class,
and the instance was named Tim, and it referenced
a dog object. Okay. So now when we created that
instance, we said, okay, so this instance, this
specific one is going to have an age of four,
and a name of Tim. All right. So it stored that
information up here in our private string and
our private int. And then later on, when we
decided we wanted to call this what said,
Okay, well give me the instance you're calling
it on. So in this case, we're calling it on Tim,
we're gonna say okay, so Tim, what's Tim's name?
Let's name is well, it's Tim. Okay, so we'll say,
Tim, what's its age, its age. That's four. So
we'll print for the screen. Now, we can obviously
create multiple dog objects. So let's copy this
and let's create a few more. We'll create three
dog objects. I'm gonna say this is Bill, and he
is seven. And let's say this is Bob, and he is
11. Okay, let's copy this and keep naming the
same thing. Let's go Bob. And let's go, Bill,
and then we can simply call the speak methods on
them. Okay, so we'll say bill, and we'll say, Bob.
Alright. And just to prove something, I'm gonna
say Tim dot speak again, and we'll talk about
why I do that in just a second. Okay, so let's run
this. Let's see, I am Tim and I'm four years old.
I'm Bill I'm seven. Then go on and you can read
through them. Okay. Now notice, when we call Tim
again, it still retains its age and its name.
When we do this, we're not actually changing.
Like this is not one variable. We actually now
have three different names right? We have Tim
we have bill we have Bob. And there's specific to
each of these variables that are storing that dog
object okay. So that means that we can hold like
unique values for each of our different instances
and we can have like infinite amount of instances
of a class okay. Alright, so That is about it,
I think I'm going to talk about quickly. I
already talked about private versus public.
Let's create some more methods in here and see
what they can do. And I'll talk about a bit more
about constructors because we're only at like,
11 minutes. So what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to create a another method. And I'm going to
call this get age. Okay? So I'm gonna say public.
And in this case, we'll say int, get H. All right.
And all we're going to do in here is simply return
the age to, let's see a return statement to
wherever we're calling from. So in this case,
all we'll say it will return this dot h. Now,
the reason I need to do this is because say,
I want to get the age of one of my dogs, right?
Like, say, I created it, I changed it around,
I don't know what it is I want the age. Well, we
can't simply do something like in other languages,
we'd be able to do like Tim dot age, right? Now
you see, when we do this, we get these little red
lines. And it says the field dog dot age is not
visible, and not as because again, it's private.
So it's not letting us see it from over here
in this main function only within this sorry,
method only within this class, can we actually
reference this variable, right. So to get the age,
what we can do is we can call Tim dot get age like
that, okay, and we can print that to the screen,
we say like, and x equals, I'm gonna say system,
dot out, print, ln, and x is already there. Great.
So now if we run this, we can see that we get
four down here, excuse me, at the at the bottom
of the screen. Now we can actually do the same
thing with like setting the age. So we wanted to
change the age at some point, maybe Tim got a year
older, well, what we would do is we have to create
another method in here, this case, we're going
to make it public. Again, we're gonna say public,
and we don't need to enter this time, because
we're just going to change something, we're not
going to return to say public void. And we'll say,
set age, okay. And then we're going to take an age
because we need to know what we're going to set it
to. And we'll just say this dot age equals age. So
just like we've done up here, is the exact same
thing, except we're just going to do it within
the method set age. So now, if I want to change
the age, so let's say instead of that, we'll say
set age, and we'll give it a value of 10. Then
we print out, let's just say Tim not speak again.
What's gonna happen now sorry, guys, I'm a bit
sick. If I keep coughing all over the place. What
I'm going to do is, oh, what's your air timeouts
at age 10? return type of set age to int. One
second here, sorry, public, let's try this. Insert
age, public void. I know I'm making a mistake over
here. Oh, okay. That's why I can't do I can't set
equal to a variable. I just call like Tim dots at
age by about on that guys. We do speak, we can
see now it says I am Tim and I am 10 years old,
and we've changed from the age of four. So that's
how we would go about changing these attributes
later on within the the class. Okay. Now I want to
do one last one, I want to create a private method
and show you what this is. Okay, so I'm gonna
create a private, void. Actually, no, let's do
it. Okay. And we're going to call this add to it,
it's not gonna make any sense with the dog class,
but just, it's just an example. Okay. And in here,
we're going to take actually won't take anything,
but we're going to return we're going to
return this dot age, plus two, okay? Now,
this is a private method, meaning that it
can only be used and seen within this class.
So say I wanted to use this add to, maybe I
could do this, I could do add to here, okay,
and just do a little semi colon. And there we go.
I could use add to, and that works fine. There's
no issues with that. Okay. And that's how you use
methods with inside of the class. So like speak,
I can easily every time we initiate the dog, call
the speak method as well. And to do it within the
class, you don't need to do like something dot
you just call the actual name, because it's
really visible within here, right? Now, what would
happen if I go over here, and I tried to use that,
so add two, so we'll say Tim, dot add two like
this. And you can see that, again, we're getting
a red line and says, This is not visible, you
can't use it, because it's a private method. Okay.
So in today's video, we're going to be going over
inheritance. So this has to do with classes. And
this is going to be how we can inherit methods
and attributes of previously made classes into a
new class, and then override methods and all kinds
of fun stuff. This is really important. This will
save you a ton of time. And yeah, so let's get
started. So you can see here I have this sorry,
this dog class that we created in the last video.
And pretty much the goal what I want to do,
at least in this video, the problem is, I want to
create a cat class that is identical to this dog
class, except in the speak method here. Instead of
saying I am whatever I just wanted to say meow. My
name is what I write right Just want to change
one of these methods to do something different.
But other than that, I want all of this to be
the same. So, intuitively, what we think we do
is, well, we just take all this, copy it, put it
into a new file called cat, and then just change
this to be what we want. Well, we could do that,
and that'd be fine. But when we have classes that
are like 1000s, and 1000s, of lines long, ideally,
we don't want to be repeating code and continually
typing like the same thing a bunch of times,
right, it also just makes it more difficult to
read. So what we're gonna do is we're going
to use something called inheritance. So I'm
going to create a new class, I'm gonna go new
class. And in this case, I'm going to call mine
cat, alright. And they'll just click Finish like
that. And then here we have public class cat. Now,
whenever we do this inheritance, what we can
actually do to inherit all of the properties,
all of the methods, everything from this dog
class is up here, when we define the class,
we can type extends, if we spell it correctly,
extends, and then the class doc like this, okay?
Now what this is going to do is it is going to
grab everything from dog class and apply it to cat
class. So this is known as our superclass because
it's kind of above the cat class. And then cat is
known as our subclass. So we have, you can also
call it a child class, or drive class. And this
could be also called a parent class, all right.
And that's because it's kind of underneath it's
getting everything from there, but then it's going
to be changing a few things, and maybe adding a
few methods to it. So typically, you start off
like the most abstract with a parent class,
and then your child classes or your drug classes
or your sub classes, because they're all the exact
same thing, just everyone likes to use different
words for them, are going to have some slight
modifications to them, and kind of work based
off of that. superclass, right? So or the parent
class. Okay. So what we need to do when we first
do this is you can see here, it already is telling
us, we need to use the constructor for dogs. So
we're inheriting from dog. But we need to use
the same constructor, otherwise, all this stuff.
And all these attributes will they're not going
to work unless we set up our class when we first
create it the same way as we did dog. So what I'm
gonna do is I'm actually just going to click on
this, and you can see it automatically generates
this constructor for us. Now, I could have typed
it out. But this is a Yeah, this is what it's
going to do. So since in our dog class, we get
name and we get age, we need to make sure that
we have a constructor inside of our cat class that
gets name and gets an age. And we have to actually
explicitly call our superclass constructor, which
is going to be the dog constructor, we're using
this formation or this syntax super. And then we
give it the name and we give it the age. Now, this
doesn't stop us from being able to type in other
properties or other attributes. So for example,
I could do something like int, and I don't know
food or something, it's like how much food they
should get, this works perfectly fine. And we can
go ahead and we can create another attribute here.
So we say private, or no, I'll just say food.
Okay, and this should say int food. And then down
here, we can go ahead, and we can just type this
dot food equals food. Okay, right. And that works
perfectly fine. And now we're gonna have, since
we're inheriting from this, we're gonna have age,
we're gonna have name, and inside of this cat
class, we're gonna have food as well. And that
works just fine. Okay. So just to know, let's
go over this again, because they've kind of gone
through pretty quickly. But all of these methods
here, we're going to be able to use within our
cat class, because we'll we're inheriting we're
grabbing all of them from the dog class. So this
cat class when we first extend it, and do nothing
is identical to the dog class. And then as soon as
we start changing a few things in here, it's gonna
become a little bit different, but still use all
this functionality. So we still have the attribute
age attribute name, we're setting them equal,
because we're gonna call this constructor method,
right from our, what do you call it super right
here. So we call this constructor. So we set up
age, and we set up name. And then we have speak,
we have get age, we have set age. Now before
I move any further, let me just prove this to
you. So if I go to main here, and I just
create a cat object, so I'll just say cat
CIM equals new cat. And remember, we have to give
it three parameters or three arguments this time,
because that's what we typed in. So for name, we
can obviously do Tim, age, we'll do 18 and food,
let's say they get 100. I don't know grams of food
or something, whatever you want to call it there.
Okay. Now I can use this speak method on Tim. So
you see, we're getting no errors here. Even though
in my cat class, there's no speak method. But
since there's one in dog, and we inherit from it,
we can use it. So I'll prove again to you
run this. I am Tim and I am 18 years old,
and that works perfectly fine. So now remember
I said though, I want this speak method to do
something else, I want to change it. So how can we
do that within the cat class? Well, the way to do
this is to just rewrite the method in here because
when we do that, we're simply going to overwrite
whatever's in the dog class. So the child class
or the subclass, whatever you want to call it.
Whenever there's something the same in here, it
automatically is going to override or overwrite
whatever is in the dog class. So I do public, void
speak. Okay, so This is the exact same name as the
other one. All right, and in here, I change I do
something, right, so I changed something. So I'm
just gonna say, system dot out, dot print ln. And
in here, what did I want to say like Meow? And my
name is what to say plus this dot name. And you
don't even add like a little food thing. And I
get fed. Let's see here, plus this dot food.
Okay, I don't know what's good enough for me,
what's the issue here? Change visibility of name
to protect it. Okay, second, I got to do something
here. Okay, this just needs to be sorry, public
and public. Sorry, this is just because we're not
actually able to see these attributes, because
they're defined in the dog class from within
our cat class. So we just need to change them to
public so that we're actually going to be able
to use them within our speak method, we can also
use something called protected, which I'm going
to talk about near the end of this video. Okay, so
right now, this is public, because I don't wanna
get into protected. But let's see what happens.
Now. If I run my Tim dot speak now and say meow,
my name is Tim and I get fed 100. Okay. And that's
because even though in the dog class we had speak,
since we wrote it again, in our cat class, and
cat class is the one that we're using, we're
simply going to take this one, and we're going to
override the the one in our dog class, okay? Now,
obviously, when we're doing inheritance,
you've already seen we can add our own methods,
we can add more stuff, and we do whatever we want,
right. So in here, I can add more methods, I can
say public void, I don't know, eat. And in this
case, we'll just have like, int, I don't know x,
like as how much they're eating. And we can say
this dot food, minus equals x, okay? And just
subtract from it however much they ate. And then
we can use eat in the cat class. But it's not
going to be seen in the dog class, right? So we
just have to understand that this does go one way,
all the stuff we do in the cat class is not going
to be visible to stuff in dog cost. because well,
dog does not extend cat, right. So it's kind of a
hierarchy where like dogs at the top, and then cat
branches off and we could have other things extend
the dog class as well. We'd have something extend
the cat class. And we can just keep going and
going and going and extending and extending and
extending. Also known as like inheritance, right?
So that's kind of it for inheritance. Now, I want
to show something called multiple constructors,
okay. So this is sometimes when we're setting up
a class, we want to be able to pass it like a
different piece of information and set up the
class differently, right. So for example, my
cat class here gives name, age and food. What
if however, I only wanted to give it a name and
age, well, we can leave both options available,
they don't have to be mutually exclusive, right?
I could give it either these three arguments to
set it up, or I could give it just two. And to
do this, we have to create another constructor.
So I'm going to do the exact same thing as above,
pretty well identical, except I'm just gonna leave
out one of the parameters here. Okay, so Second
Age. And then here, we'll simply call super,
and name and H guy. And you'll see no red lines,
everything looks fine. And what we're essentially
doing here is we're giving it another way to set
up the cat class another way to construct all of
our attributes and set up the cat class. So we can
either call the cat class using three parameters
or three arguments, or we can call it using two.
And you know what, maybe we could set one up only
using one, we're only using zero. So let's do
one with one just to show you how this might
work. Okay, so if I do string name, and then int,
age, okay. And then here I call super. Sorry, I
should just get rushed. actually get rid of this,
because we're only gonna use one right? My bad.
I'm going to give name. But what about age? What
am I giving super for for our age? Well, I don't
know. How are we going to set it up? If they only
give us one argument? Well, I would think that if
they don't give us an age, then we should just
automatically assume that their age is zero. So
let's do that I'm going to put in zero, just hard
code that in here. So that way, this means now say
for example, they only want to give us a name,
then we'll just automatically give them an age
of zero, they want to give us a name. And in age,
that's fine, we can do that. But maybe what we
should do in here, if they give us a name and age
is we should make sure that food is set equal to I
don't know, maybe let's give it a default value of
50. So if they don't define how much food the cat
eats, we're just going to assume that they eat 50.
Okay. And this is kind of a way you can do like to
know when I was like default parameters. If they
don't type something in just automatically set
a value for that. So that everything still works
fine. I hope that makes sense. So let's show now,
the three different ways that we can create a cat.
So cat, Bob equals new cats. And in this case,
we'll give it a name. So we'll say Bob, and we'll
give it an age of seven. And no red lines. This
works fine. Again, this defines a cat right
because that's another constructor that we had.
So let's do this one more time. And in this case,
let's just only type a name. We're going to name
this One do, like the name Joe. Alright. And
there we are. So now we could obviously do
like Bob speak. And we could do, Joe does speak.
And these are the three ways that we have that we
can define a cat. Okay, so Meow, my name is Joe, I
get fed zero, Bob, I get fed 50. Right, it can go
on like that. So again, when we have one, now we
just seen a quick error that maybe we want to fix,
we should probably give them food as well. So we
say this dog food equals 50. Okay, as like our
default value for how much they get fit. So that
is a way that you can do multiple constructors.
And now I'm going to talk about protected values.
So protected values are something that we can use,
similar to private and public. But they're, they
just act a bit differently. So pretty much if you
use the protected keyword instead of public
when you're defining things. So for example,
here in my dog class, I'm going to go up and
change public to protected. This means that only
things that are within the same package, or are
subclasses of the class can have access to this
pretty much like name. Okay, so that means any of
these files, or any of these classes within this
package are able to see this. But if I had another
package, which you typically do, if you have large
Java programs, anything in there would not be able
to see this. Okay, so with whenever we're using,
what do you call it whenever we're creating
like a main class or a parent class? pro? tid.
Wow. Okay. We're going to want to use a protected
keyword, at least for what do you call it, sorry,
our attributes so that we can change them access
them from within the sub class. All right. Now,
for these methods, it's fine. They're public
anyways, right? So we can make these protected as
well, if we didn't want another package to be able
to access them. Now, if we create private methods,
right, if we create a private method here, I'm
actually going to try this. I don't remember
if this is going to allow us to use this
now out here. So let's say like Tim dot,
let me know which one I changed. Get age.
Okay. So Tim dot get age. So int x equals See,
this is gonna work. Yeah. So again, this is not
going to allow us to use this, because well, we
made it private, right? If we made that protected,
it would allow us to use it here, but not outside
of the package. Now, I want to try this though,
and see if I can get this uses get age from within
our cat class. So if I do, for example, when I
want to speak, I'll say this get age Ed. Yeah,
so this isn't working as well. Which means
that, again, if we want to use those methods,
we have to make sure they're either public or
protected, rather than private, okay? The only
time you really get to create private methods
is if within the class is the only area you're
using the map that so for example, maybe you're
doing a math calculation, and you only do that
from within the class and you don't want anyone
outside of the class to be able to do that, then
you create a private method to do that, because
you could do that from within the class, right.
So in today's video, we're gonna be going over
kind of class variables and the keyword static.
So you may have seen that we've used static
and a few things in like our main thing here,
actually, I'm going to delete all this. It says
static right here. And no one's really explained,
I guess I haven't really explained what static
means. And that's what I'm going to be doing in
this video. So let's get started and talk about
class variables. So right now we have something
called attributes games, we have these two
attributes, which are specific to each instance of
our dog. So when we created multiple dog objects,
each dog had their own name, and their own age,
and other dogs were not affected when we change
one of the dog's name or one of the dog's age
unless that dog was that obviously, right.
And that's great, because we can have a ton
of different values that are specific to different
objects or different instances of this class. Now,
sometimes, we want to have variables that will
change or are the same for each instance. So
we can change them in one instance. And if we do
change it on one instance, they will change in the
other. Now, those are known as class variables,
not instance variables, because instance variables
are like kind of attributes, okay? The way that
we can create these class variables is we can do
something like this. So yes, let's say protected
again, say protected. And by the way, I'm just
in my dog class, I deleted a bunch of stuff out
of it, just to make it a bit easier to work in.
And I still have the cat class, but it's just
I'm not using it for this video. Okay. So we'll
say protected static int count equals zero. Now,
I know that that is a mouthful. But what we're
doing here essentially is we're creating a class
variable, which is an int, int count equals zero,
which is protected. Okay, I know it's a lot
of keywords. But what is the static keyword
do so what this is actually going to do is it's
going to allow us to statically change count,
which means it's not going to change for each
instance, it's only going to change or sorry,
it'll change like that. All together, right? So
what I was explaining before, and that's what
this static keyword is going to allow us to do.
So we don't actually care about what instance this
variable is a part of, we just care that it's a
part of the class. Alright. So if I want to change
this value x, well, I do need still need to call
this and I can say this dot count, equals, and
then or actually, I'm gonna say plus equals one,
okay? Because what I want to do with this count
here, consist, I feel dogs should be accessed in
a static way. Okay, let's just do this one second.
Okay, what I'm doing here, sorry, one second,
I'll explain this is I'm just gonna add one to
this count, because I want to keep track of how
many dogs we have. So that if I wanted to, I don't
know, like, see how many dogs have been created,
I could just simply call like dog count, and
then figure that out. Alright. So what I'm doing
here, instead of calling this count, which does
actually work, is I'm calling dog count. Because
since this is a static, variable, or static, yep,
static variable, class variable, whatever you
want to call it, it doesn't actually care about
what instance I'm changing it on, because it's
going to change for all the instances. So I can
actually use the name of the class to change it.
And that's why it gave me that little yellow line.
I'm not sure if you guys read that. It said we
should do this in a static way. Because Well,
it's a static variable. So I could, however, call
like this count, right? And that would work fine.
Because this will is an instance of the dog class
who knows where to look for the variable count,
but it's much better to do dog count, like plus
equals one. Okay? Now, I'm going to prove this to
you that this does indeed actually work. I'm not
just making things up. So let's create some dog
objects here. Say a Tim or dog. Tim equals new.
Wow, typing is not great today, new dog, and we'll
say 10, and score nine for age. And we'll just
copy this and what should we do? Let's do bill,
maybe, say, Bill, and that is new dog name. Bill,
age 10. Okay, now, since this static variable here
is protected, I can actually access it from me.
So what I'm going to do to change count in order
to print count out first of all, is I'll prove to
you that system, system dot out, dot print, ln, I
keep thinking, we're in Python here. And I'll just
simply print out dog dot count like this, okay,
and just see what we get as a value First of all,
okay, so we get to, so we already know that this
is indeed working, because well, when we added one
to count, if it was different for each one, then
it would just be one. But anyways, and if I want
to change dog count, what I can do is I can say
dog dot count, let's say equals like seven. Okay?
And that's fine. That works. If I print out, dog
count, we get seven. Now I'll show you two. If I
do like Tim dog count, this will give us the same
answer. So you can see we get seven. Even though
in Tim, we didn't do anything with Tim to change
count. Since it's a dog part of the dog class,
it has this count variable, and it's changing,
obviously, within 10 as well. Okay, so that's kind
of how the class variables work. Now time, let's
talk about static methods. Okay, so this was a
static variable, or class variable, I like to call
a class variable just because it's what I'm used
to, but you can call it whatever you want. Now
we're gonna talk about static methods. And what
that is. So it's very similar to this, kind of the
way that this works, but is a little different.
So I'm going to do here man type, public static,
void, display, okay. And in here, all I'm going to
do is simply do system, dot out dot print, ln, and
I'll just print. I am a doc. Okay. So what this is
doing now is I'm saying static void display. Now,
in here, what's going to happen essentially, is
we don't need an instance to call this. So I can
actually just call this on the dog class. So I
can say, like dog dot display, like this. And
since it's a static method, this works fine. And
this one didn't say I am a dog. Now, as opposed
to if this was a regular method, so let's just
make a regular method to kind of do a comparison
here. So public void, and we'll say, display to
okay. And we'll literally just take this and put
it word for word in here, just to show you the
difference. So now watch what happens if I tried
to do dog dot display too. You can see that we're
getting a red line and saying that we need to make
this static because we need an instance to call
display to meaning that we need to have first
create a dog object. And then we can use that
dog object to call display to or we can do like
this dot display too. And that works fine because
that's calling it on the instance right? Because
this represents the instance that we're using. So
the static is going to allow us to call it just
simply using dog but the thing was static is it
has no way to access are, what do you call it? Our
values are our attributes, right? So if I wanted
to access like a dog's name or a dog's age, well,
I can't do that for a static method like, I can't
type like this dot age, that just simply doesn't
work. Because if you think about it, well,
what what, what instance are we calling it on,
there's no instance, we're just simply calling
it on the dog class. So we have no idea what
age to look for, or what name to look for. So the
only time we use static methods is when we don't
care about the instance. And we just want to do
something and we want to store it within that
class. You can almost think of it as a function if
you if you know other programming languages. But
that is ideally how static works. So whenever you
want to build a call something and you don't care
about the like the instance, you don't care about
the attributes, you can make it static, and that
way you can call it without having an instance. So
yeah, so hopefully, that makes sense to you guys,
I'll quickly go over what this void does one
more time, in case anyone forgets, remember,
in our functions, we can return values, when you
put void, all this does is say we're not returning
anything, we're just going to do something,
right. So we could be like manipulating an array,
or in this case, printing something out to the
screen, okay, or maybe getting like input from
the user, but we're just not returning
any value back to the call statement.
So in today's video, we're gonna be going over
how we can compare objects, and how we can get
a string representation of different objects.
And you'll see what I mean in just a minute. But
these are really useful. And I guarantee you guys
will be using this a lot, especially if you have
objects, like maybe like point objects, or like
some kind of mathematical objects that you'd want
to compare, without having to make things too
complicated for yourself. Let's just say that,
right. So what I'm going to do here, and what I've
already done, I guess, is I have the student class
set up. And this is just what we're going to work
with right now. Because the other classes I had
in previous videos were already like finished, and
they had other stuff in it. So we have a student.
And currently the only attribute the student
has is a name, okay. Now, in my main Java here,
I've just created a few different students.
And then I'm just gonna be printing something
out to the screen. So that's why I have that
right now. So we can see student class, right,
we just create a name for a student. Now I just
want to show you quickly how we would go about
like comparing objects intuitively right? So say
I wanted to check if Joe and Bill were the same,
right? Like if I want to see if they were equal to
each other? Well, we know how to do that already.
So what I would do is I'd say like Joe is equal
to bill. Now, intuitively, you probably say, well
know, their names are not the same. So they're
not going to be equal to each other. And well,
that would be correct, but not for the reason that
you think and all demonstrate that to you. So we
have Joe and Bill compared to each other. So watch
what happens if I try to make these the same name,
right? So you'd think well, these would be
the same object, or they'd be the same thing,
right? Because they have the same name. But watch
what happens when I run, we still get false. Now,
why is that? Exactly? Well, pretty much we
use this double equal sign on two objects,
right? So like Joe, and Bill, the computer
doesn't know how to compare them. So by default,
what it does is it compares the actual object. And
you see here how we're creating a new student. So
a new object. And here we're creating another new
student, another new object, these are actually
two different objects, like in memory, okay, so
in your computer's Ram. These are two different
entities. And they're completely unique. Although,
yes, they have the same name. Since we can change
names, and we can do things. These need to be
separate objects. So when we compare here, it's
actually saying, well, we're going to look and see
if these are the exact same object, and well, they
are not. Now that's useful in some cases, because
sometimes you want to see if it's like the exact
same object. But in other cases, we want to see if
these objects have like the similar values, right?
So in this case, we probably want to compare the
two names of the students to see if they were the
same. And in that case, we would say, Well, yes,
these are the same student, we're going to say,
Yes, they are, they are the same, right? When we
do that, like double equal sign. So what I'm gonna
do now is I'll delete this. Let me show you how we
can go about doing that. So inside of our student
class, I'm going to add a method, okay. We'll call
this public, Boolean, not Boolean Boolean. And
we're gonna say equals, and then here, we're gonna
take a student object known as other, okay? And
then we'll go like that. And there we are. So what
I'm gonna do in here is when we want to compare
our students, okay, we're going to pass another
student, and we're going to compare their names,
right? So we're going to call this dot equals on
one of our students that already exists. We're
going to give it another student, and then we're
going to see if they're the same. So how do we
say we're going to check the same? Well, we're
going to look at their names, okay. So what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say if, and then we'll
say, this dot name, and I guess I need a brackets
here as well. always forget about those. If this
dot name equals equals Okay, and then we'll say,
other dot name, then what we'll do is we'll simply
return true. Okay? Now otherwise, so if these
names are not the same, what we will do is we
will return false like that. Okay. And that's all
we need to do for our dot equals. So now, what's
gonna happen right is we'll pass on one student,
we'll call this we'll check name, and then we'll
check the other student's name, see if it's true,
if it is, or if the same will return true,
otherwise, it will return false. So now we can
try this out. So these two are the same names.
So let's say is Joe dot equals, and then here,
I guess we will put a bill. So let's run this.
And you can see we get a value of true. And then
if I change bill, back to say, Bill, then we
can run this, and we can see we get false. So
now we officially have something checking for
equality between the names. Now we could create
more kind of ones like this, like equals grade,
like whatever if you want to do that. But this is
how we can check for equality between objects.
And this method is like really easy to add in.
Obviously, if you had a student with a bunch more
values, maybe you had like grade, maybe you had
other stuff like that, or like a last name, you
could check to make sure those are all the same.
Or you can just kind of customly do it the way
that you want to say, two different objects are
the same, right? Okay, so the next thing I want to
be able to do is compare things using like greater
than sign or less than sign, right? So I want to
see if like, Joe is greater than bill or bill is
greater than Tim. And we should intuitively like
do that based on alphabetical order, right? So I
can't really show you like a way to do it here cuz
I don't think it's gonna work for my show. Greater
than bill. Yeah, see, that just is undefined,
there's no way to do that. So we're going to do
is we're going to use a method called compare to,
okay, what we have to do to compare to, is we have
to, what do you call it, sir, we have to implement
something into our class. So when I say implements
at the top of our class, I'm gonna spell it
correctly. And we're gonna type comparable. And
then in here, we're going to do student. Now what
we're actually doing here, when we bring this in,
is we're actually implementing something called
an interface. Now, an interface I'm going to talk
about in I think, like two videos from now. But
pretty much it's just like a set of methods that
we have to use for the class to work. So when
we implement this comparable thing, that means
we're allowed to bring in a method that is going
to allow us to compare two objects. Okay? So what
we'll do now, is we will say, public and actually,
what is the thing for this the return type public
ins and compare compared to, and then in brackets
here, again, we're going to take students, and
this will be other, we'll put our brackets here
like this. Okay. So now again, we're gonna have to
return some kind of integer. And I'll show you how
that works. I just got to get it up on my other
screen, so don't mess this up. Okay. What I'm
gonna do now is I'm going to return this dot name,
dot compare to, and in this case, we're going to
compare it to another string. So the other string
will be other dot name, okay. So essentially,
what this is going to do is it is gonna compare
this name to this other name, and it's going to
give us an integer value saying kind of how far
away they are, right? So it's, it's kind of hard
to like explain. So I'm just actually going to do
it from over here. And you'll see what I mean.
So if I go Joe, dot compare to, and then against
to bill. Let's see what we get. We get a value of
eight. Now what this means is Joe is greater than
bill by a distance of eight, meaning that
when we compare these first two letters,
they are eight away, I believe, okay. So if we
want to check if Joe was greater than bill, what
we do is we check if this integer value returned
was greater than zero. So here greater than zero,
that's going to tell us true if Joe is greater
than bill and false if he's less. So we run this
and we get true. Now, let's see if we compare Joe
to Tim. Okay. So t obviously is ahead of j in the
alphabet, so we get a value of false, okay, and
if we get rid of this greater than zero, then we
can see exactly what we're actually getting as a
value. So negative 10, right? Because that's how
far away j is from T one, we're comparing them and
that's what the compared to does for us. Okay. So,
if we wanted to check if Joe was less than 10,
then we check if this value was less than zero,
in this case, we get true. So that's a really easy
way that we can compare different objects using
that compare to method Okay, so like this a public
int compared to and you just have to remember to
implement comparable students. And then you can
use exactly this return statement here. Now,
the last thing I want to show is a string
representation of an object. So once you First,
what happens when I just want to print out
my object to the screen. So I want to print
him. And maybe ideally, I'd like to see like
Tim's name, right come up to the screen. Well,
look what we get here, we get tutorial, one dot
student app, and then all these different letters.
What this is printing is actually the memory
location of our object. So all of our objects
are actually stored in memory, in RAM in like
really fancy ways that I can't really explain to
you guys. But anyways, this is like the address
for it's like, when the computer looks it up,
this is what it's actually using to find Tim and
find all its values. And obviously, it's telling
us where it is in the tutorial one, like folder,
file, whatever, okay? So this is no use to us,
we this does not help us as programmers at all
we want to see like something that's a string,
and gives us some valuable information. So
what I need to do is I need to implement a
nother method here, that's going to change this
to string. So we've used this.to string before,
but this is exactly what I'm going to use, we're
gonna say public string. And we'll say, to string
like this, okay. And what we're gonna do in here
is we're just gonna return a string representation
of our object. So what we can do essentially, is
I can just return this dot name, and this can be
what we're going to use to represent our object.
Now, typically, you might see people do something
like this, okay, and just follow me for one
second. They do student and they have a bracket,
and then we're gonna add this store name. And then
they add that with another bracket. So this way,
you'll see when I printed out to the screen,
what it looks like, okay, we get student, and
then Tim. And this is just simply telling us that
the object we're printing is a type of student,
and the name value is Tim. Okay. And we could
even get more fancy. And we could add, like,
double brackets around this name, if we want
to show that this dot name was a string type,
okay? Now for our purpose, I'm just going to
get rid of this student and this bracket here.
And you can see again, when we print this, it
goes, Tim. Now notice, when I'm printing this,
I'm not actually calling this two string method,
like I'm not, not doing.to string. That's because
Java actually knows that when we have this two
string method in here, this is going to represent
a string, right? So when we try to print it, it's
automatically going to call that.to string method.
Okay. So now, what we can do is we also just
call like two strings, so I can, if I wanted to,
I could just call.to string like this, and I
could convert it to a string. And this will work
the exact same way as before, you can see we get
bill, okay. Again, in here, you can change this up
however you'd like. In some cases, like say your
student had some grades, maybe you want to write
their name. And then after you have like an array
of all their grades or something like that, okay?
Now, inner classes are pretty, pretty easy,
actually, all they are, is really just a
class inside of another class or inside of a
method. And I'll show you some examples as we
go along. But since we already know all about
classes and methods and static and whatnot,
I'm not gonna explain too much of it, I'm just
gonna kind of show you how we can create instances
of inner classes in different ways. So I'm gonna
start by doing these incidents outer class here
that I've already created. can see on the side
here, I'm just gonna create another class called
intercourse right now, in a class is just gonna
simply have one method in it. And I'm just gonna
make this a public void display. And in here, all
I'm going to do is simply just display something
to the screen. So we know that we're actually in
the rights class here. Okay. Let's say this is an
inner class, okay? And what's our error here,
class at token interesting. must have made a
mistake somewhere here, one second guys. Oh,
sorry, I put these two brackets here. I don't
know why I added those anyways. Okay, so this
is an inner class. Now, outside of this class,
I'm going to create another method that's going to
be a part of the outer class. Okay, so this class
is actually contained within the outer class,
meaning that currently, since it's private, we
can only actually access it from within our class.
So if we want to create an instance of this, that
means we must need a method in our class to do
that. So in this case, I'm gonna say public void,
inner, and in here, we're going to take nothing,
and all we're going to do is we're gonna create an
instance of our inner class and just display Okay,
so we're just gonna say, inner class I N equals
new inner class like that. Okay? And then all
we're gonna do is just call i n dot display, and
make sure that this is working. Okay, so now our
class is finished, we have an inner class and we
have these void inner and all that does is create
an instance of our inner class and printed to the
screen. Again, note that this is private meaning
we can only access it from within In our class,
okay, so now if I go to my main dot java, I can
run a command so or whatever create an object so
we can see this. So first of all, what I have to
do is create an outer class object, so that we can
call that inner class. So outer class out equals
new, and then outer class. Now it is worth noting
that I don't have any constructors here, meaning
that I don't need to give any information to my
outer class or my inner class when I first call
it and that's why I can just leave these blank
brackets. Okay. So now if I want to see my inner
class, what I have to do is I have to do outdoor,
enter. Ok. So we'll call that method to create
the inner class, and then run that. So let's
run quickly here. And we can see we get this is
an inner class. Awesome. So that's working fine.
Now I'm just going to make this public. Now I'm
going to show you how we can do this from outside
of the class. So right now what we need to do is
we need to create an instance of outer class. And
then we need to call the method inner, to be able
to create the inner class. And that's because this
was private. But now that it's public, we should
be able to create an instance of it outside of the
class. So the way that we do that is we still
need an instance of outer class, because this
class is defined within outer class. So we need to
first create this so that this is kind of created,
right? As we did that, we have outer class.
Now what I can do is I can say, outer class,
dot inner class, okay. And we'll just call this
one i n equals lowercase equals out, which is
going to be our instance of outer class dot. And
then in this case, we're going to inner class
believe this is correct. But I guess we'll see
Oh, I probably need an equal sign. And we'll type
new new outer dot inner class. And let's see what
our little red line is create class inner class in
package out. Interesting one second, guys. Okay,
so that's what the issue, I knew it was something
like this, what we need to do is we need to do dot
new, and then inner class because we're creating a
new instance inside of this right of outer class
of inner class. Okay. So now what we've done is
we've created this i n, which is an object, which
is a new inner class. So now we can simply use i
n, which is an instance of inner class, right to
display. So now we can do a i n dot display. Okay,
so if we run this, see, this is an inner class,
and that is working fine. So those are two ways
you can get access the in a class. Now, right?
Now, you might be like, hey, well, why the heck
would I do this, because now it's just like a ton
more lines? Well, there's many times where you
don't really care about like this instance, and
you just want an instance of the object inside of
it. So in that case, this would make more sense to
do. And obviously, you will most likely have more
methods than just one you're gonna be using. Okay?
Alright, so now that we have that, I guess, let's
show creating this kind of inner class. So I'm
going to delete this inside of a method. So we can
actually create these inside of methods, which are
really useful because sometimes within the method,
we want to use a class and we don't want to have
to define like a new file for another class.
Okay. So we have this public void, enter. So I
guess let's just work with this right now. You
don't even leave in a class right now. And let's
show you how this works. So all I can do in here,
and I can say, we can do public private, in this
case, I'm just gonna say I'm going to say class
to class in a class. And then here, yes, that
works fine. We're just going to redefine display.
So we'll say, public void display. And now that I
think of it, I probably could have just copied all
my other code, but whatever, get some practice
typing. Print ln, and then in here again, this
should probably be a T, we will just type inner
class, okay. So this is going to work perfectly
fine. Whenever we call this void inner, then we
have this class inner class, we're going to create
an instance of it, and we're going to display it.
So if I run this, I guess, wow, I really should
just kept all that code. That's fine. Why is this
not giving me an autocrat outer class, out equals
new and outer class and brackets. And then in this
case, we'll simply just call out dot enter. Okay,
so now we can see what should happen is again,
we should print in our class. So there we go,
and we get in our class. Now pretty much you can
do this like wherever you want. The reason I'm not
saying this is public or private is just because
like it's already within this void. So to use it,
we're gonna have to call this void. So there's
no really there's not really any point in putting
like private or public But again, like if you
wanted to can type public class inner class,
or Oh, actually saying you can't do that. So I
guess I was right the first time. So since it's
inside of this void, you're only gonna be able
to use what we call this. So there's no point
in really giving it like a public or private
method, or class name, sorry, because in here,
we can still do public and private methods,
because well, outside of the class, we might
be using those methods, right. So you can see
obviously, since I'm creating this instance,
inside of the, the voids inside of inner,
and if I tried to do that outside of it,
it wouldn't work. Because this class is only
defined when we call the inner method, okay? Now,
interfaces are either unique to Java, actually,
because I haven't heard of them in any other
languages, but they're somewhat similar to
classes, they have to do with like inheritance.
And anyways, you guys will see as we go through
the video, but they're pretty useful. And yeah,
they're an important part of Java, so we need to
learn them. So what we're gonna do first of all,
is we're gonna create a new interface.
Now, just like we create a new class,
we're just gonna right click on tutorial one,
our package, go to new, and instead of class,
obviously, we're gonna click interface. Now,
I'm just gonna name this one vehicle for the
example that I'm going to be doing. So we'll click
vehicle. And that's all you need to do. There's
no like, you don't have to package generate
comments, that's fine to do vehicle. All right,
now we have an interface called vehicle. So
what is an interface? Well, pretty much it is
something that is completely abstract. Now, this
is kind of a new concept, but it means that we're
not actually going to like you can't create an
instance of an interface, all it's meant to do
is to be inherited from. So if we have a class
like car, for example, that I've created here,
car could implement the interface and use it.
But we're never going to create an instance of an
interface it just here, so that we can implement
it into different classes. hope that makes sense.
So inside of our interfaces, and you'll see
in a second, we can only have public methods,
and we actually don't define anything inside the
methods, or the the attributes. So when I create
a method in interface, and I'll just make one
now I guess, I'm going to do, let's see here,
void, speed up. And we'll take as a parameter
into a, that's all I do, when I create a method,
I don't put those, the brackets, I don't do
anything inside the method, I just create
this. Now, you could see that this is completely
abstract, because it doesn't actually do anything,
it just defines the fact that this method exists.
So similar to when you create a variable and you
don't give it a value, that's kind of what we're
doing here. Because we're gonna use this in our
car class. And you'll kind of have to go through
all that before you really get to understand. But
when you create a method, just know that you don't
give it any content, all you do is just say, like,
this method will exist in any of the classes that
implement this. Okay, so I'm going to create a few
methods here and already call it like a attribute.
And then we'll just move into actually using the
interface because the easiest way to understand
it, so I'm going to say, we have speed up, we're
gonna slow down. And we'll have to go change gear
as well. Just going a classic example that we're
gonna implement a vehicle from a car and you guys
will see what I mean. Okay, change gear. Okay,
and then I'm gonna add a attribute. Now, any
attributes that add in here, like variables,
whatever you guys want to call them, they have
to be final. Now, I'm not sure if you remember
in the last video, but final means that it's
a constant and it cannot change. Okay, like,
we can't change this value. So I'm going
to say final int, a equals and then let's
just say five. Okay, actually, or let's just go
gears, okay, like Final interviews equals five,
saying that each thing we're using is going to
have five gears. Now watch, if I try to just do
interviews equals five, that still works, but it's
not going to work in the way that we want. Okay,
so just make sure whatever you're doing
this, you make them final, if you want
to have like variables or whatever that you
want to use in all of the different classes,
they must be final. Okay. So right now, we've
defined three methods, and we have one attribute,
which is just called gears. Okay, so how do we
use this interface now? And how does that how does
that work? Well, the way we use it is we've typed
implements and you might have seen this before,
and then the name of the interface in this case,
vehicle, okay, you can see already that we're
getting a red line, we're getting an error.
So there's nothing wrong here because we can
implement it but car saying the type car must
implement the inherited abstract method. Okay,
so that means that since we've defined these three
methods here inside of our interface of vehicle,
we have to define them inside our car class. So
whatever methods we put here, if we implement
one of the interfaces, we have to define them,
because right now they're completely abstract.
And if we call them well, we have no idea what
to do because there's no content for them,
right? So we're gonna have to create a void
which is change gears. I'm gonna say public
void Change was calling viewers or gear.
Let's see change here. Okay, so change gear,
and then it's gonna have to take one parameter. In
this case, we're gonna say int gear, so like, what
gear do we want to change? Okay? And then we're
just gonna go up here, and we're just gonna say,
private int gear, because we're going to define
that when we when we change gears, right? Okay,
so now we're gonna go to and make another the
other one that we need. So let's just check here,
we need speed up. So we'll say public void speed
up. And in here we'll have speed as like what
speed are actually not speed, we're going to go
into change. So how much we're going to speed up
by, and then we'll do one more. So public void,
slow, down like this. And again, we need this
change. And there we go. So this now we're getting
no errors, because we've implemented all of the
methods that were abstract over here. Okay, now,
gears, we don't need to do anything with it. It's
just like, if we wanted to use it, we could,
okay. So what I'm going to do now is inside,
I'm actually gonna create another private int, I'm
gonna call this speed. Okay. What I'm going to do
now is I'm going to just just fill up these,
what do you call these methods, so I'm gonna
say when we change gear, we're just gonna say,
this dot gear equals whatever gear we're changing
it to. And then for speed, I'm gonna say, this
step speed, actually plus equals change. Okay,
and then down here, we'll say this speed minus
equals change, game. Change. Perfect. Okay. So
now what we're gonna do is we're actually just
gonna add one more method just to show how this
works. So we've implemented the things we need to
implement from our interface. And now what we're
going to do is we're going to just create another
method. So in this case, I'm going to make this
like a display method so that we can display our
car pretty easily. Okay, so public void, display.
And inside of here, I'm just going to print out a
few things to the screen. So System dot out dot,
print, ln, and in this case, we'll just say, I am
a car, comma, and then we'll just add, actually,
let's say going and how fast we going we're going
this start speed. If we want to get out like a
little kilometers per hour, so let's do that. And
I am in gear, and we'll just add whatever the gear
is. So this stuff stuck here. Perfect. Okay,
so let's now actually use this. So we have our
interface vehicle, okay, and we have our car. So
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna create car
objects, we'll say car. I don't know, let's say,
Ford. Okay, equals new car. Okay, perfect. And now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna say car dot.
Ford, I guess is what we need to do Jose for speed
up, and let's maybe change it to 10, we'll add 10
to it, I just realized that we're actually gonna
have to make this speed default at like zero, and
gears, let's just do that default zero as well.
Otherwise, you're gonna run into an air arshi
gear, I guess you can't really be in gear zero.
Can you just change that to one? Okay, perfect.
Okay, so for speed up, and I will say Ford change
gear, and let's just change the gear to Okay. And
then if we want to display our Ford, we can do
Ford dot display. Perfect. Okay, so let's run this
now and see if everything's working. So we say I
am a cargo in 10 kilometers an hour, and I am in
gear to perfect. So that's working fine. And we've
implemented all that stuff from our interface
vehicle interface. So now I'm going to show you
some cool things, we can add into our interfaces
that make them a lot more useful. So say, for
example, you've used a bunch of interfaces with
a bunch of classes you've inherited from them.
And now what you want to do is you want to add a
method to all of those classes that are inherited
from it, well, what you could do is you could do
the same thing here, and you could type something
like this. And then you could go into every single
one of your classes, and you could change them to
be whatever you want. But if you want the method
to be the same for all of them, we can actually
use something this is why interfaces are kind of
useful called default. Okay? So we type default,
and then maybe in this case, void, and let's just
say like outlook, we're gonna print something out
just to make it easy. What we'll do here is we'll
just, we can just create a method and we can use
this from any of the classes that inherit our,
our interface, okay? So I'll do here they'll
say system, dot out dot print, ln, in this case,
I'll just say default method, okay. I know very
creative. How did I just spell system? And I okay,
anyways, alright, I'm tired guys. I apologize
System dot out dot print ln default method.
Okay. So now that we have that, from within
this car class, we can use that default method.
So say when we display, we want to print that. And
then we want to do the default, what we could do,
I believe, is we can say, just out maybe. And yes,
that actually works fine. So now that we have out
because that is a method within our vehicle class,
and we implemented, let's see what happens when we
run our program, we get a cargo tank one mission,
our gear two, and then says default method. It's
using that default method that we created inside
of our interface. Now, I believe we can actually
use static methods as well. So this would be known
as something that's not a static method, because
we have to call it from within our, our class, but
we can actually create static methods within our
interface that we can then just call statically.
Like, we don't have to have an instance to
call them. So if you don't know what I mean,
just follow along for a second, as I'm going to
create a static, I don't know, let's just do like,
int, let's return something, let's change it up.
Let's just call this math. I feel like math is
a keyword. And that's fine, we'll just do math.
Okay, we're gonna take int B, and all we're gonna
do is we're just gonna return b plus not okay. I
know very basic, but that's all we're gonna do,
just to prove a point. So now, saying, I'm in
my main job, all right, and we get rid of this,
we don't create a car object. And I want to use
this static method inside of my interface. Well,
what I can do is I can do vehicle, dot, and then
you can see it already has this function coming
up here, this method dot math, give it a value,
like five, I'm just actually set this equal to a
variable. So we'll say x equals that. And then
we can System dot out dot and see what we're
actually getting as a value. In this case,
we should be getting 14, right? Yeah, so 14,
there we go. So let's see, you can create a static
method inside of your interface. So in some cases,
you can kind of think of these as functions.
All right, say you had unless you don't,
I'll just do one as an example. Because this is
kind of useful. If I go new interface, and we
call this math, okay, then inside here, you could
do a bunch of static methods that will do like
math operations for you. Like maybe you have the
quadratic formula, maybe you had, I don't know,
like Euclidean distance, I don't know a bunch of
different math formulas, you put them on this math
interface. And then when you want to access them,
you would come in here and you'd say, well, math,
dot maybe like square root like sq. RT, okay. And
then there, you'd be able to use all of those,
I want to call functions, but they're really
methods inside the, the interface really
easily. So that is a really good example
of when you can kind of use interfaces.
Now, enums are pretty much a collection of
constants that we can reference. And then we
can do things with those constants. And they
are pretty cool and just make your code more
readable. And yeah, you guys will see when we
go through the video. So the first step is to
create an email. Now to do that it's similar to
creating a class or an interface or whatever,
go to your package, right click, we're gonna
click New and then you know, so for e&m, I'm just
going to name mine. Actually, I'm just gonna name
mine level, because you'll see why it makes sense
for this example. So again, the syntax here is
is public e&m level, rather than like class or
interface or whatever, right? So in here is where
we're going to define our constants. Okay? Now,
this is really useful, because we don't have to
do like public static, and whatever like the name,
like we can literally just type whatever value
we want our constant to be in, typically,
it's a string. So in my case, I'm going to
go for level, I'm going to go in all caps,
you don't have to go all caps, we're gonna
go high, medium, and low. Okay, now, these
are the three constants, I'm going to store in my
level iums, we have high, medium, low. And yeah,
that's literally all I'm going to do right now,
for my e&m. It just means we have three constants
that we can reference from level and these are
the three. And obviously, you can do as many as
you want. And just keep going with commas on and
I think you can put them on the same line as well.
It just makes them more readable if you do them.
Like other lines. Okay, so every three constants,
now I'm going to show you how we can actually use
this email and you'll start to understand how it
works. So to use this enum, we have to create a
new instance of it. So to do this, I'm going to
say level, and we'll say LBL equals new. Actually,
I think it's like this was level dot, and yes, we
say a high, low and medium. So my guess we'll just
pick a low, and I'll put a semicolon. And now you
can see it's all showing up in different colors.
And this is working fine. So now that we have this
as a constant, we can do certain things with it,
right? So typically, you might want to check what
value your constant is like what value is levels.
So we can obviously use these in an if statement,
like so. So I say like if elvio equals equals and
then like it's level dot analyst, Start out low,
I guess. And we'll just work our way up to high. I
mean, say l if our elsif. And we'll say LBL equals
equals, and then level dots and medium. Okay,
we'll do something in there. And then finally
else, because if it's not lower medium, it must
be high, then we'll just use me. So in this case,
we'll just say system dot out, dot print, ln.
And we're just gonna print level for all of them,
because I want to show what this does. Okay?
What the heck did I just do there? Okay, anyways,
now we're just printing level each time. And
actually, let's just run this down and see what
happens. So you see, we get low. So when we print
out level, it's simply just gonna print like,
whatever the constant is that we have. And that's
because it has a little.to string method built in.
So we can convert these into a string. And I'll
show you what I mean by that. So pretty much
say we wanted to get this because right now like,
it's not a string, it's not an it's not a Boolean,
we don't really know what type it is, it's just
like in level it gets an enum. So to actually
get this as a string value, if we wanted to do
something with it, or store it, we can use.to
string. So if I say string, we'll say E. Yen,
why not? Why not? We'll say is equal to lbl.to
string. And that's just going to convert this to
a string for us. And then we can do all our string
operations or whatnot with that. All right, so
to get it to a string. Now another really useful
thing that you notice is we actually get all the
different values of enums and print that to the
screen. So where do system dot out? dot print ln.
And I believe the way we do this is to do level
dot values. Yes, there we are. So we go level dot
values. And if we hit that, or we type that in,
you're going to see when we run this, now, it
gives us what is actually giving us an array with
the values. So when we try to print that we're
getting like, you know, the memory address of
it. So once we have these values, so I'm actually
just going to store this an array so that we can
then iterate through it and print them out. What
I'm gonna do is we'll say, level array. And this
is the way you have to do it, let's say arr is
equal to and then level dot values. Case, that's
working fine. So what we're gonna do now is we'll
just create a quick for loop. So and I'll show you
how we can loop through all the different values.
So say, for E, or home, which would be this level,
level E, and then we'll say, in ARR, what we'll do
is we'll simply just print out, E, okay. So system
print out E, and then we can see all the different
constants that we're going to get. So just go
here, and you see we get high, medium, low, and
then just prints low. Again, just because we're
doing this if statement here, okay. And that's how
you can loop through all the different values. So
that's really cool. But you might say, Okay, well,
that's cool, too. But is this really that useful?
Like we just have these constants? Well, there's
a few other things that we can do inside of this,
you know, add some methods, and some instructors
as well, so that these constants actually point
to certain values, kind of similar to like a hash
table or hash map that I showed you before. So the
way that we can do that is we need to create first
of all a variable that's going to be private. So
in this case, I'm going to say private, and I'll
say, actually ends level LBL nom, okay. So this
is going to just be a private value, that's just
going to store the value of each of these. So like
low, medium, high value of all these levels.
So just set this value, what we need to do is
we need to create a constructor for our IEM. And
you'll see how this works in a second. So I'm just
gonna say public level in and then none. Okay? And
in here, what are we getting here? Remove invalid
modifiers legal modifier for short only private
instrument. Okay, so let's do this. Private,
sorry, my bad private, because we're just gonna
call it on here, you'll see in a second private
level int num, and we're just gonna say this dot
LBL, num is equal to num. Okay, there we go. So
now what I can actually do is you see how these
are highlighted in red. So since this is a private
constructor, that means we're going to define
this variable based on what constant we choose
for the enough. So I'm going to put brackets here
and I'm going to define highest three, medium as
two as low as one. Now, what this is going to do
is it's going to keep our same constants of high,
medium and low. But when we create a new constant,
it's going to activate this constructor of level,
and it's going to set this level non equal to
whatever value we put in the brackets here. So in
this case, 321, we could obviously have multiple,
what are called parameters here, and we could have
multiple arguments here and we can have a ton of
different values. And yeah, so the only issue is,
since this value is private, we're going to need a
way to access it from our main here because that's
probably where we're gonna want to use it. So that
means we're gonna have to create a few methods to
will change that level num and to get that level
num so we've done this before, but Actually,
I don't think I can do a public. Eye we'll see
if we can public gets level. And then in here,
we'll simply return. Guess it's gonna need to be
an int, public int get level will simply return
this dot, LDL num. Okay, yeah, so that does work
fine. I just can't do a public constructor. Okay,
so this is just going to give us the level num. If
we called get level on our keynote to change this.
What do you call it? level num. What I'm going
to do is I'm going to do set LBO. And so having
interior it's just gonna be a void. Okay, and all
we're gonna say is this dot LBL, num is equal to
num, and then we're gonna put in here, int, num,
Okay, perfect. So now what we're doing is we have
a way to not only get the level num, but to change
it. So now let's try using this out in our main
and see how this works. So I'm just going to get
rid of all this stuff, because we don't need this
right now. So right now we have our level and it's
level dot low. So to actually get the value of
this level, we can use something called get value
of or we can use that method that we had here. So
in this case, I'm going to say get level. So what
I'll do, as we'll say, system, dot out, print ln,
and in here, we'll say elvio. dot. And then what
was the thing we were using get level like this.
So now if we print this out to the screen,
we should be getting one. And indeed We are,
we're getting one. So now I'll show you this
thing. It's called get value of Okay, and is it
x value ever get value? I'm not sure we'll see. So
I'm pretty sure if we do something like this level
dot value of Yes, that is exactly what it is. And
then we pick a we type in whatever the enormous
so in this case, we could say, low, it's gonna
give us Let's see, what's the issue here. Okay,
so the issue is, I just got to put this in string,
I just forgot about that. So I do level dot get
value of and say I put a string in here. So like,
say someone was typing in and into the computer,
and they type in a string, right, and you want
to pass this in to get value of we see what we're
actually going to get is we get low, right?
Because that is the value of this string.
In the enum. Although it's not a string, it
can like determine that, okay, so that's what
value of is used for, I can't really give you
any good examples of them. Cuz I don't really
know any good examples of using value of but
for any of you that might see some use in it,
I figured I would show it to you. So I guess we
can do an example. Now just setting the level just
to make sure that all that is working, say elvio
dot set level. And in this case, let's say five.
And then let's just grab this again, actually.
And we can delete this row up here. And now I'm
just simply going to print out, record elvio dot
get level, and just make sure that everything is
changing and working fine. And there we go,
we get a level of five. So that is how we can
use itams. Pretty much they're used for when you
want to have a collection of different constants,
maybe you want to loop through, see what those
constants are. And it just makes a code kind of
readable, right? So we have level dot low, and
then that low can point to like five to one,
whatever. And that's all stored within our enum
right here. Obviously you can have as many items
as you want and you'll really see the use of
them further on in Java when you're creating
like larger programs. Okay, so anyways, that has
been it for this video. If you guys enjoyed please
make sure you leave a like and subscribe
and I will see you again in another video.